uh it's a little bit after 1 101 102 I'm
going to go ahead and open uh today's um
uh session uh we have eight bills to
review um and uh four of these bills
have new fiscal notes that are brand
spanking new um so there's there's that
and then we were providing provided with
some additional information um by U
folks like the child advocate and all so
uh of these eight bills um about five of
them seem fairly complex that we need to
understand what is happening what the
processes are that's going to change and
the new work that's being required
because it's that incremental workload
that's going to um uh Drive the cost
and and so we need to understand you
know the basic concept of of many of
these bills
um before we really get into this I want
to welcome um our you're sitting in
today for
Laura representative tersi is uh doing
something important with her daughter um
so we have a a guest star here today and
want to permanently introduce um Mr
David priest he's U now a fully
functional member of uh division 3 in
the finance committee uh he comes with a
comes to us with uh this this one year
under his belt as a representative and
he hasn't had any ethical challenges so
so that that that makes you rare and
good uh and um he comes with a
tremendous background the only thing
flaw I can find is that he's a
university of Wisconsin fan so and I'm a
Nebraska fan but uh other than that I
think we're probably going to get along
do do you want to introduce yourself you
you have a very impressive resume all
kidding aside it's a very impressive
resume thank you very much um it's an
honor to be with you today and for the
rest of the year that's all I'm going to
say I have my work cut out okay so we're
going to put him down in the modest
category too he does have an impressive
resume but I don't want to steal his
Thunder um all right so with that like I
said we have eight bills uh I would like
to start with um Mr David weers from the
Department's it department and and the
reason I'm I'm starting with him is
because there's um there's five of the
eight bills require
it updates and modification and so I
just want to knowing what I thought I
knew about the workload of your
department and your implementation of of
modifications and upgrades in support of
the commissioner strategic plan I just
wanted to make sure um that that we had
a conversation about any concerns you
may have about um potentially having
five new it syst system upgrades uh
dumped on you particularly when some of
these bills say they go into effect 60
days after signing or go into effect
immediately so not much time to
implement a
change thank you my name is David
weeders the information Services
director for DHHS thank you for the
question representative Edwards and
chairman um with the exception of hb1
1573 we sure I administrative problem um
my uh secretary is uh is not here he's
introducing another bill could could
could one of you take notes um and and
until uh representative Stringham
returns is that is that you
representative
H
okay all
right might I ask a question while we're
waiting for him to get that up yes sir I
I noticed that we did not include HB
1363 on the agenda and I'm just
wondering that's another one that that
you know they came through with an FN
note through this past you know the past
few weeks is that something we're going
to wait and hold off till
the I I have a visibility issue uh go
ahead Mr Ripple I think uh first of all
I think that passed more recently than
these some of these might have been from
a few weeks ago it didn't okay well I
think there was some confusion also
whether it would whether it belonged in
division one or division 3 it's my
understanding that it'll probably come
to division 3 uh but obviously it hasn't
yet been scheduled so we'll try to get
that scheduled for the near future so so
that sounds like the one that um I just
got this afternoon and it was a tossup
between 1 and 3 and I took it because
I'm trying to schedule another followup
to this session on Monday afternoon and
we'll add it Monday afternoon because it
didn't show up on today's calendar I
don't think we can hear it okay all
right are you ready okay so this Mr
David
weers thank you for the record David
weeders Information Services director
DHHS um as as it relates to these bills
with the exception of HP
1573 which we're still working on an
updated fiscal note for worksheet for we
believe that we have the resources
necessary and most of the bills
introduce nominal systems changes so
they won't be full upgrades but they
will require us to identify the
reporting impacts as well as the system
impacts to achieve the different goals
of each of those bills the associated um
dollar amounts for the work on each of
the bills are for the research needed
the regression or the testing needed for
the systems to ensure that the reports
and the systems um operate properly and
go into production
in regards to the 60 days subsequent to
the bill passing on each one of those we
would need to address how it may impact
our Contracting process um which would
not it takes longer than 60 days for us
to update a contract with funding I
would defer to Nathan if he has
additional information um to answer your
question representative Edwards so so so
I have two one is I think the least cost
up upgrade is is
$290,000 and and that
$290,000 is listed for both 1564 and
1595 it those could be it could be a
coincidence that the two bills have
similar child support words in it and it
may be a coincidence that the it upgrade
is the same cost I just I just want to
know if that's really you know one
upgrade or or two upgrades es of both
bills
passed do and that you may not have an
answer for that right now yeah I I don't
have the answer for that exact question
but I
can take that back to the team and and
validate that it is either two separate
or Nathan might have additional
information hello Mr White would you
read your name into the record good
afternoon members of the committee uh
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
with the Department of Health and Human
Services um to answer your question
representative Edwards um when we
receive a fiscal note request from the
LBA we look at the we look at the
language in the bill and our
interpretation of that and then we
conduct our analysis on those costs so
it may just be a coincidence that those
numbers are the same but but those
estimates are based on what we see in
the bill and what we expect to be the
anticipated cost so those were done in
isolation and not
concurrently I I suspect it as much um
so um on the possib we're not going to
be voting on anything today obviously
we're going to come back Monday
afternoon uh to to relook at all of
these plus plus one more bill um and on
Monday afternoon if if I could just have
a a a simple analysis on if those two
bills uh 1564 and 1595 if if they both
got
passed uh what would what would be the
it modification or upgrade cost in that
in that situ instead of 290 * 2 is it
290 * 1.2 or something sure to see if
there was some sort of cost savings we
could achieve upon passage of both
correct right yeah right because because
they sound like they're doing something
similar to changing that information
system and so it just feels like it
could be one one upgrade instead of two
but um now uh Mr weers uh
1573 says something about a new it file
management system and it doesn't have a
a fancy uh systems name so so I wonder
is that going to be a roll your own
thing or are we going to implement a
change in an existing system and we just
didn't name
it so currently we're we were evaluating
um utilizing either New Heights our
integrated eligibility system or our
bridges system for children youth and
families however upon looking at the
bill we also identified that both of
those Solutions do not have this file
management certification process in them
so they would be a new lift for either
of those systems or a brand new one and
that is what we're updating on the um
updating updated fiscal note that would
be presented back to
you um I know I didn't answer your
question directly the the reality is we
we believe we we would need a new system
to provide this
service okay so would you build the
system or would you buy the
system um our normal practice following
dit's direction is to buy the system
instead of build it and in terms of buy
it would be putting it out to bid and
getting a getting a vendor to vendors to
respond with their solutions for the
system so so um I'm just going to check
that real quick because um that that had
a relatively short fuse suggested
implementation date or effective date um
uh sections six through uh nine go into
effect July one of this year and the
remainder in January of 25 and if you've
got a go contract for a new it system uh
the question would be could this program
really go live without the it support or
would we be creating other problems now
that that's kind of a unwieldy question
that maybe you can't answer but it it's
a concern of mine that if if we we we
can't go live in practice unless you've
got the right support so um do you do
you have a feeling of that should we be
thinking about pushing that date
back
in terms of moving forward with a new
solution that requires an IT system to
be effective at monitoring and and and
in not in managing and sharing that
information effectively I would suggest
moving the date back so that we would
have time to um requ do go out to RFP
and implement the solution which is a
about 9 to 12 month time frame for us to
do that based off of our procurement
practices so my request there is not for
an answer now
other than I mean you you told me what I
needed to know but to try to come back
Monday and maybe this is too quick if
you could sort of thumb wrestle this a
little bit more so we know what your
strategy would be and what your
recommendation would be on on a
different implementation
date fair enough we will definitely do
that we we'll get the analysis and do
that work this week and have something
for you on Monday okay so uh represent
ho your just for clarity you mentioned
four bills I believe in the very
beginning right that you were discussing
I just want to make sure I captured
which four bills they were I I think I
said there were five uh bills that had
it implications on them and I can I can
yeah just so you want me to read those
to you yes please um
[Music]
1564 and
1595 you and and then I I I have not
looked yet at the other Bill
representative Earth have have you
looked at the bill that we haven't
looked at yet I've looked at the bill
but I haven't paid attention to whether
it requires doit work okay do you recall
the number the of the bill
1363 1563 13 oh 15 13 133 13 63 13 63
okay so um so could you take a look at
1363 as well for Monday to tell us you
know I don't know if it has an IT
implication or not but it if it does
it's the same general set of questions
about do you have the capacity to do it
and what's kind of timeline would be
rational we will add that to the list
thank you sir
so we're what we're doing now is we're
just trying to focus on the it thread
all the way through these bills so that
we can let Mr weers go back to work
because uh I know uh he he's got tons of
it um is there anyone on the committee
that has any questions related to the it
components of of these
bills do you have any words of wisdom
before you
leave I reserve those for the members of
this committee but thank you very much
so so just how about an update a really
quick update H how are you doing overall
implementing all of the Commissioners
priorities are you do you have a backlog
in projects or are you guys on top of it
are you ahead of schedule or behind
schedule generally I would say in
general we're on schedule I wouldn't say
we're ahead of schedule of every project
we're ahead on some and we're on
schedule for others there's of course
some projects that we put on hold based
off of resources being focused on some
other efforts um but when it comes to
behind schedule um anything that would
be in our project management portfolio
indicating um behind schedule we address
with risk mitigation and identify how to
get them back on yeah where possible
yeah so what I'm hearing is we do have
some projects that are identified to
support commissioner strategic plan that
are on hold due to Resource limitations
and we could potentially be dropping
five more projects on you without
appreciating the relative priorities of
those other on hold
projects thank you for the clarification
representative the um as
it relates to the commissioner's
strategic plan we are on target for all
of those items we do have additional
projects that are it addition to the
Strategic plan that may be put on hold
at different points in time to support
the Strategic plan but I don't see any
issues with the current strategic plan
and unless Nathan has additional
information that's outstanding thank you
um that that that's all I have on it I
don't see any other
questions thanks for coming by good
seeing you again thank you very much
it's good to see
you okay with that I think we can go to
uh house one and um so we're starting it
a little bit late but but I think being
out of sequence will help us overall who
who's who's up to introduce uh 1588
relative to court
jurisdiction uh representative long said
he was going to
send um uh representative her her first
name is Gabby but uh
Gabby Gman um she's I don't see Gabby or
representative
Gman um so
um so representative walner would would
you mind just introducing um
representative Longs
bill it's it's
1588 relative to court jurisdiction and
of course we're not going to ask you
questions this is just a performa
int introduction of the
bill uh yes go
ahead thank you Mr chair and I am um
here to introduce House Bill
1588 um for representative long who is
the U Prime sponsor and this bill
pertains to uh Court jurisdiction over
persons receiving special
education uh thank you for that uh is
there anyone from the public Miss
Rosenberg do do you happen to know
anyone that may want to talk on
this hi Karen Rosenberg from the
disability rights Center I think that
this is an effort that perhaps the
school district attorneys would want to
speak about um because think that they
worked with representative long on this
bill I can tell you I can give you some
background about what it I'm aware I'm
familiar with it so when the legislature
changed the eligibility for special
education for students with disabilities
to make the maximum age 22 the day
before they turned 22 as opposed to what
it was 21 um the provisions in the
juvenile laws that that address
continuing jurisdiction for students
with disabilities were not similarly
amended to reflect the change in the
eligibility for special education and so
what can happen is for students that are
in one of the 169 BC or D programs if
they have a disability and get their
Educational Services and residential
services a lot of times or intensive
community- Based Services through their
Court involvement if they if this law is
not amended when they turn
21 they will not have the opportunity to
extend their jurisdiction so that they
could continue getting those additional
supports um and what we've seen in our
office is that there are students who
like don't have a home to go back to
maybe they were at Easter Seals
residential program for example and
they're 21 years old they haven't
finished their high school programs
because they haven't earned a
diploma they turn if they're they
because of like an abuse and neglect
case turned 21
then they are unable to finish their
education programs because there's not
like a day a place for them to live to
finish those programs so it's a small
number of kids I think who are affected
or 32 is what got cited in the fiscal
note that I I have no idea that sounds
about right but I don't know is is there
anyone from the legal society that you
just
mentioned um I don't think they consider
themselves a society but there's a law
firm that was working on it
I I don't see them okay
so so I I representative long and I
talked last night and he's got uh some
family issues he's taken care of and he
thought uh he could have a
representative here as well as um
somebody who had looked at this three
people he said worked on it extensively
from like a legal perspective really
attorney Jared zelen worked on it a lot
he with Drummond Woods um I don't see
him here I know that the schools were
really concern you spell his name so
that we can make sure he gets invited
Monday um Gerald j e r a l d
zalin wor spell her z e l i n if you
give me a moment I will he's with
Drummond
woodsom and I can I can give um Kevin
the information I got him in my contacts
okay um so um
so I'm just going to make some comments
and if you want to respond to any of
them you're welcome to if you if you if
you don't feel like they're in your lane
you you don't have to perfect okay so as
I look at this bill I I I look that it's
talking about
32 individuals is there anyone from the
Department here ready to talk about this
yeah come on up I'm so sorry I
overlooked your your do do you want me
to stick around or no go ahead yeah it's
you know we're having a friendly team
day good afternoon Susan larby general
counsel for DCF so I was looking at the
uh fiscal note as well and trying to
extrapolate that those numbers and is
that your question I'm about to get
there yeah is there anything you want to
say overall programmatically before I I
start drilling into
it no not at this time okay so so my
concern as I look at this is that it
seeks to service an additional 32 kids
and it overall there's a request for
four additional
FTE the FTE are two additional DHHS
employees somebody from Child Protective
Services somebody from the juvenile
probation and parole office so that's
that's four people to handle 32 more
cases and it's
generating uh an an estimate of of about
say we'll call it 1.65 million to as
high as 5.76 million and so uh if you
want to just sit at the end there Mr
White and you can use that microphone it
that's just an
enormous range and I don't understand
why we would have such a huge
range good afternoon members of the
committee Nathan white Chief Financial
Officer um chairman Edwards if if the
committee turns to the last page of the
bill um or uh to the fiscal note the
last page that's probably the best place
to start so we're assuming that there
would be an additional 32
individuals um that that would still
fall under this this particular section
of
Statute and as a result of that we made
two assumptions here or several
assumptions um one is we assumed 22
would still remain within child
protection and 11 would be within the
juvenile justice system and you'll see
in the table the position costs those
are for three positions um it's the
second to last line there uh two of
which would be working within child
protection system one would be jpo to
cover the additional increase in case
load um the other costs that you're
seeing there um relative to the total
1.6 million estimated in fiscal year
25 the residential cost so last budget
cycle we talked a lot about the
residential contracts and the additional
Appropriations that this committee had
made towards that um that's the cost
that we estimate where we would need
additional funds to pay for children
that were in those Residential Treatment
um facilities um the communitybased
services those those are services that
that are provided um to children and we
have a number of existing contracts and
that's the estimate um based on the best
information that we have at this point
in time um where we would see an
increase in cost there and then we have
that onetime Bridges system New Heights
update for the
$100,000 that that helps us get to that
total 1.6
million I missed the it the new new
heights uh is it where is it written
that I just I overlooked it oh there
it's right there last page on the in the
table Yeah I just see it now so I would
ask Mr weer about that too because that
makes six of these that has uh it
implications
okay can somebody get that to Mr weers
all
right all right
um is there is there anyone who can
speak to the to the question that given
that it's so many new people it's three
it I you thank you for correcting me I I
I just wrote wrote a bad note so it was
three um this says it goes into effect
60 days after its passage uh if it's
going to require an upgrade to or an
update to new heights you know it's it's
the you know which comes first uh
question and I think the system may need
to be updated
before uh the this program should be
expected to start so I I think I think
if the department could just take go
back and look at at what the it
implementation expectations would be and
when the go live expectations would be
then we could adjust the the the write
up there absolutely I I think another
thing to consider here um if if we're
looking to get as accurate as possible
as as we evaluate this is if we look at
um the position costs as well um because
if this bill passes July 1 and it takes
effect 60 days later we have to
internally go through the process of
formally establishing the positions and
we have to work with the Department
administrative services to do that then
post the jobs and then hire them um so
if if we do um if the committee does
consider pushing out the effective go
live date I think we should also keep
that particular element of this in mind
relative to the appropriation that that'
be great so so all of that could
potentially change this fiscal note
again perhaps in the first year but in
the long run we'd still have a long-term
impact right are are there questions
from the committee on 1588 go ahead
representative wner thank you um I guess
this is for Mr White all of these
children are presently in
residential care at this
time my understanding is that this
estimate was based on the on the numbers
that we have today that that would Age
into this if this bill were passed okay
so they they are all in so don't all of
these children already
have um a juvenile
justice provider service
provider yes but we would have other
children that would be coming into the
system so we'd be expanding the overall
need of the system um and to do so
without having the additional resources
to do so may not be
prudent do does anyone know what the
case load is of a a Services
officer I don't have that information
with me
today is that possible to get that
maybe the and the number of juvenile
service officers we have and what the
what the average case load is at this
point thank you of
course I I think those those are great
questions because if we're adding
basically 32 on top as an increment I it
just makes me wonder what the actual
work is per individual and whether that
adds up to two more CPS people and
another juvenile uh go ahead
representative H thank you chairman I'm
not sure who at DHHS could answer this
but I believe there are currently a
waiting list for Hampstead Hospital in
the same age group through 18 is that
the case
the the the weight list fluctuates day
by day I I would have to find the most
updated information because some days we
don't have weight list other days we do
is
there if we spent money over there would
that solve some of the weight list
issues is it a capacity issue of the
facility or
staff are we talking about child
protection or are we talking about
Hamstead hospital I'm a little confused
Hamstead Hospital relative to juveniles
who might be coming through the the
justice system who need right
Residential
Care well welcome Miss
Tilly good morning you've got the JV
team my name is Patricia Tilly I'm an
associate commissioner with the
Department of Health and Human Services
fairly new to this work so I don't have
all the answers for you right now
representative um I would just note um I
think your thought is great around
Hamstead but I would note that these
kiddos in these youth young adults that
are in residential care may not be
appropriate for hamstad care they may
not have a psychiatric diagnosis that
would be appropriate so that's really
the main point that I would put in this
um and again to the point that the
weight list does vary day by day but we
are generally close to full it is mostly
based on
Staffing thank you I I realize that this
is not so much about that those would
need juvenile Services through Hamstead
the reason I was asking is given
spending of a versus B if we have
children under the age of 18 who are
waiting are on a wait list at to
Hampstead that might be a higher
priority for us as a committee to
consider did did you you moved do you
have a question or comment I have a
comment if that's okay um so a lot of
these children have development
disabilities and are also eligible um
potentially for services under one of
our 1915c Medicaid waiver programs and
so when you're considering what the
fiscal impact is it one way or another
um the department will probably be
helping to support the res if they need
Residential Services it would still be
funded in part by the department so I'm
not sure that it's a dollar for dooll
amount that that would be you know
caused by Chang changing the law in this
fashion the difference is that it would
enable these students to be able to
continue to reside if they're in
residential programs to reside at those
residential schools um Because unless
the court extends the jurisdiction then
there won't be a funding mechanism for
that because the
1915c waiver funds cannot be used for a
residential
school just a quick one so so I'm having
a hard time wrapping my head around the
fact that these folks exist with these
needs and they're part at least
partially in the system are they just
not getting services I don't I don't
quite understand if they're I'm sorry if
you finish no no I was basically done
good Interruption go ahead so um you
know I this is not necessarily all the
children but some of the children that
or young adults that have come through
our office are um students who have
developmental disabilities that are
pretty significant and they're also
connected they are in the um abuse and
neglect system and they are duly
eligible for developmental Services
Under the waiver as well as school
services so and and there are there
there's been litigation around um you
know what the obligations are for
students right now um and that's
something that's sort of current being
hashed out a bit I mean although so
that's a little bit complicated but um
either
way um what we're talking about our
students who are going to benefit from
continuing to receive their services
where they are as opposed to having to
leave where they are to go into Adult
Services if they were to drop out of
school uh thank you there several people
have walked in would you to take a look
around to see if the folks from from
that Law Group are now in the room no no
would would you I'll I'll call him when
we're done and let them know you thank
you I was so hoping to hear from them uh
could we could you make sure you talk to
Mr Ripple to so that we I will give him
all the contact information and I
personally will give Jerry zelen a call
the attorney who's been involved with
this okay I I think um representative
long really wanted us to hear from them
so so representative Mooney and then
representative ver thank you very much
thank you for being here as a point of
historical reference this change in
eligibility to the age of 22 was that
implemented just last term well actually
was implemented in two stages um last
term there was actually was two terms
ago that there was a bill that was
passed actually the House and Senate
both passed the same bill to raise the
age to 22 last session there was like a
cleanup bill because there were a couple
areas of Education law that didn't get
amended when the definition of child
with a disability was changed to add up
to 20 what they call 21
inclusive thank
you so I'm probably a little dense um
but not so these kids these people are
currently in the the system and
currently in residential Andor Community
Based
Services I'm still not clear given that
I'm still not clear on why there's such
a wide range of possible costs when you
actually have real costs before you
now um representative Earth so if we
have a population of individuals in the
system today and one year goes by and if
this bill were passed they would still
be within the system and we would still
have those costs we're assuming ass
uming though that we're going to have
the same behind there increase you know
as people age into the system or come
into the system I I I don't see this as
being uh net neutral because we're
basically expanding the total
eligibility for the system um and our
assumption and and we basically straight
lined it going forward so individuals
that are currently in the system that
would no longer be in the system that's
the that's the the 32 figure that you
see we're assuming there would be an
equal number coming in there so so when
we're when we are developing this fiscal
note and we're looking at okay from a
ratio perspective if the number if this
if the Staffing number and I still need
to confirm this I believe jppo is 1 to
11 and Child Protection is 1 to 10 we
would assume we would assume we need
that same number of staff and then the
res the res rate and the Community Based
Services we're also assuming based on U
utilization ratios today X number would
be in residentials treatment which would
cost x amount per person and X number
would be in commun would be receiving
Community Based
Services I would just also add that the
real if you look at the fiscal note the
real differences come in the cost of
residential care so Staffing Community
Based Services those those may be
different um but it's really the Acuity
of the care that that the individual may
need and so those costs can be variable
depend on the need of the um
youth okay so I was only looking at both
because those are the two actually vary
and and I understand the most of them
are residential um I guess I'm still
curious as to how this range is coming
into place I mean you could come up with
an average right now which if you
multiplied that out would give you a one
number um is it is is the range of
Acuity so incredibly variable that you
wind up in a situation like
this I would suggest that's that's
possible how about we assign likelihood
H we can go back and have further
conversations about that but and and
determine if we can understand that a
little bit more but I think what we were
trying to express is that there they are
very varable based on the needs and
based on the uh facilities in which we
find Residential
Treatment okay so here's one way you
could look at it when you kid kids start
at a pretty young age in these programs
potentially I
assume again it depends on the need okay
but you have kids in a range of Ages
across the program yes okay and you have
kids in a range of Acuity across correct
the program so you do have some idea of
the average of Acuity and therefore the
average of cost if you're looking at the
whole program and not just these 32
kids we can go back and look at that in
a little bit more detail thank you and
we can have that for
Monday representative Murray thank you
Mr chair um I know I'm the sub but I'm
just real curious about something uh
when this bill passed two years ago or
so you know to move the age from 21 to
22 wasn't there a fiscal note attached
to that addressing what y'all are
talking about now and when I was looking
at this I was assuming that this is more
changing the statutes to address things
that got dripped behind and I'm curious
ious about why would there be a new
fiscal note assuming that with when it
passed two years ago there was an
appropriate fiscal note at that
time may I summarize your question a
little
differently M Mr White is this money
already in the budget
and no we're we're this this bill would
expand the population of individuals
that would be eligible to receive
Services I think that's key and I think
that's why you're seeing our assumption
that there will be an increase in
residential treatment utilization
there'll be an increase in case load
which is why we would need the
additional positions followup yeah thank
you um just curious wouldn't you have
predicted the increase in students when
the bill was passed two years ago you
would have assumed that there would be
students that are aging out of this I'm
just curious of how the the
process
good afternoon for the record I'm
Rebecca Ross the director of The Bureau
for children's Behavioral Health um and
previously General councel and
legislatively as um for dcyf when this
bill was originally brought two years
ago to make the change to the special
education and educational system
structure there was not a corresponding
change for the Department related
services so those were were not included
in the fiscal note or the Appropriations
this is to catch up with that
change no I
understand all right so um are there any
other questions on
1588 is is there anyone Miss Tilly that
wants to say something
wise I have very little wise things to
tell you but you did ask ask about the
CPS number or the numbers um for case
loads CPS assessment is about um eight
um case loads CPS family service 13 jppo
is
15 and so those are numbers of
individual
cases yes that is the number of cases
each individual would would typically
have or have on average now so an
argument could are could you make the
argument here that you're using a
conservative ative number for these
additional two people because it's 16
per yes all right representative
Hall thank you for CPS assessment folks
it is they have a case load of eight CPS
family service they have a average case
load of 13 cases for jppo average case
load of
15 any other questions
any other
comments yes you have a comment I can't
help myself I mean another thing to keep
in mind is that the overall goal for the
Department that's been expressed
multiple times is to reduce the use of
institutional placements of children so
although these students may be you know
residing in residential schools and
require that the hope is and where I
understand the department is going is to
try to reduce the um our dependence and
Reliance on institutional placements for
kids so that might be something to
factor into this as well as the we don't
know that 100% of the students who turn
21 are going to want to take advantage
of extending the Court's Jurisdiction to
you know not everyone wants to be under
Court's Jurisdiction just another thing
to keep in mind as you weigh through all
of this thank you okay uh well thank you
for that and um with that I'm going to
conclude House Bill
1588 and I'm ready to move on to
um this bill um this bill the prime
sponsor is someone we all know
representative walner and what she and I
talked about um is that uh she's going
to go ahead and introduce the bill um
and not um and and not take questions I
don't want her to take questions so she
can return as a member of the committee
and and ask her questions there um and I
and I guess I should have done this so
so you're starting clean on 1598 and
representative hle has the prior Bill
okay so it's just a merger issue
um go go ahead are you ready to you you
you can introduce it from
there House Bill
addresses um a concern that has come
forward and I think I've been here for a
long time and I don't think I was even
clear that this was happening
um when children go into foster care or
care of by the state when the state
takes um jurisdiction and um takes the
care of children if a child enters that
system and they have a Social Security
Disability um payment or because they
themselves have a
disability or their parent has a
disability or in some cases children's
parents have died and they don't um have
they are receiving uh some sort of a
death benefit from their family for
their
family and
there are though I don't know how many
of these we have or if we have had any
at all and I hope we haven't had
children who have had to go into child
placement whose family have had um whose
parent has been a veteran who may have
who may have um died in service um and
so they would receive a veteran's
benefit for that um we the state is
taking those payments and actually
deposit depositing them into the state's
accounts as opposed to setting those
payments up for the children a lot of
these kids when they age out of foster
care or Residential Care um they have no
family to go back to they have no
resources um you know who they are they
end up children that young people who
end up
homeless they have no car to get to work
they have no way of continuing their
education um and so what this bill does
is um stop that practice of um the state
taking those uh
payments there is now a new fiscal note
which I think will be uh passed out the
first fiscal note
was fairly
amazing um but there is a new fiscal
note which I'm sure the department will
be able to explain and and talk
about it it feels like this is happening
all over the country many of the states
are doing this they're moving this way
um and the federal government is
actually um encouraging states to move
away from holding taking these uh
benefits from the children and putting
them into the state's account to cover
their foster care or their parts of
their Residential Care
um I think I'll just leave it at that
I've got all kind I've got loads of um
articles and information from other
states I've looked at a number of states
this the um bill before you was actually
modeled after the Arizona model the
Arizona uh legislation so um and I'm
glad to provide any and all of that if
people want to ask me about getting some
of those articles and some of those
other States I'd be glad to get them for
them okay uh thank you is there somebody
from the Department that wants to speak
to this
bill you basically you know how how how
do you all see the problem and how do
you see this as um the right precise
solution and and the number of children
that'll be affected good question go
ahead and chairman Edwards for the
record John Williams I'm Le director of
legislative affairs for Health Human
Services and with me is Attorney Laura
young I'm litigation Council for the
Department of Health and Human
Services and everybody knows U our Chief
Financial Officer Nathan
Way well uh chairman Edwards I just want
to start off in terms of the financial
analysis that was done uh on the leg on
this particular Bill we completely
understand the goals of the Prime
sponsor and we certainly work hard to
try to come up with solutions to some of
the barriers that have uh come up one of
the issues that we have is that we have
identified the need for additional
Staffing Resources within the department
to be able to actually do what the bill
is requiring us to do uh we do currently
have a policy in place uh that is at
least dated as of December 2022 uh that
identifies that we do assist in the
application process for these benefits
under Social Security Administration and
Veterans uh Affairs benefits uh for
children who are disabled or have
disabled parents or the parents are
deceased so we do have some uh level of
assistance that we're providing to those
individuals but the scope of this
legislation would expand it to all
children within our our category of
placement with the um department and
that's a sizable number and because of
it we need the resources to be able to
actually actively not only work on the
application process but the legal issues
that also come related to that including
going to appeals before the Social
Security Administration it would also
require us as part of our exercise to
place the money that we'd be receiving
in essentially a trust for the child we
Hampshire uh we do things well and we
protect assets and that's why we have
some of the most stringent Probate Court
laws uh here in the nation and it's one
of the reasons we would need legal
support to be able to manage those funds
uh additionally around that that's kind
of the big picture where our we're
running up against some issues around
Staffing and would need those resources
the the other piece of this uh is the
loss potentially of the title for E
funding in foster care it's a balancing
out between um uh deciding to utilize
either SSA veterans benefits or the
title for E funding for purposes of the
cost of placement for for these children
so there are a lot of complexities that
are involved we we were looking into
working with The Advocates I will say
that the New Hampshire legal assistance
and also the disabilities rights Center
have been particularly helpful in the
conversation uh around this but one of
the issues is how could we reduce the
cost if we could identify an entity
outside of the department to take over
essentially acting as a guardian on
behalf of the J at least administration
of of these funds so I'm going to stop
with that and ask attorney uh Lori Young
who's actually the expert next to the
person who at least knows the high level
uh for any additional commentary and
thoughts in terms of some of the
challenges that we faced in terms of
trying to identify making this workable
uh but at the end of the day uh
regrettably it is a sizable amount of
money even with the Revis fiscal
analysis provided by the department
which Mr Ripple was kind enough to
provide to you in your your packet here
uh today so so so I just want to make
sure that uh for the committee
everyone's looking at the new fiscal
note 24-
2311 is is that that's the right one
right 2311 it should say revised today
yeah revised today
um okay and I don't I don't know that I
heard a number of U people that would
benefit from this
change representative Edwards um I I can
speak if if it'd be helpful relative to
the number um or the numbers if if it's
helpful for the committee to understand
the update fiscal note um which which
may help inform um and and and address
your question in
directly the new fiscal note dated
3624 uh that is before you so as as John
had indicated um this new bill would
require that we determine whether every
child coming into the system is eligible
for SSA or veterans benefits that is not
something that we do today there'd also
be a require
uh every year that we would continue to
check that again that is not something
that that we currently do today and
relative and I I'll let the attorneys
here at the table speak to some of the
complexities uh relative to page one
line 19 um and and the special
trusts today we currently um use the SSI
benefits that um and and representative
walner we do have an update in the
fiscal note there are actually
individual accounts for each child in
which we receive the SSI funds and those
funds today are used to pay for the
services that those children receive and
so that's approximately in and we were
able to run uh State fiscal year 23
numbers with the additional time that
that we received and today um for for
safe fiscal year 23 it was approximately
$1.4 million in
SSI uh Revenue that we used to offset
General funds the second component an
additional
$773,000
um So currently we're claiming title 4E
for about 25 children a quarter and if
we were to um receive SSI benefits for
those children on their behalf we would
no longer be able to claim that
73,000 estimated annually um in title 4E
so in total we the state would uh
increase its general fund needs or
obligation by about $2.1 million
annually in addition to the the uh the
resources that would' be needed um to
conduct the evaluations and and I don't
know if you want to speak to some of the
complexities yeah so you will notice in
the the bill it identifies several ways
that when we're talking about uh
safeguarding the funds for these
children children there's several
identified ways they give examples of a
Special Needs Trust of a stable or able
account of a pooled trust all of these
options are are very good in
safeguarding they're also complexity in
in the legality of making sure they're
done correctly and they're done
correctly for each child because each
child could have a different need and
what they might uh need in the future
and then also how many benefits they're
getting and the reason it's important
the Safeguard is because each one of
these kids are going to be on a
different type of benefit most of them
are me test for example Medicaid we want
to make sure and ensure that we are have
that adequately protected so that we
don't end up
um going over the means test and then
having those benefits go away the the
complexity of each one of those is it's
not a one-size fits-all and then
additionally for each one of those
options you have to have someone that
manages those funds for a special need
trust that's a trustee a pool trust that
has an organization that does that like
in our state ELO Enhanced Life options
or for a stable account you have to have
someone who is overseeing that account
and making sure is being used in the
appropriate ways because there are a lot
of rules about how money can be used in
these protected areas and if you allow
misuse of that for example if it's used
for rent or food that can actually
invalidate the entire protection and so
there's ongoing responsibilities that
require a lot of legal um oversight to
make sure it's done well and done
right okay just just a heads up on what
we're going to do we I I don't know that
we're going to finish all the questions
on 1598 uh so we may recess
1598 to start talking about
1573 because
1573 includes some funds for the
judicial branch and division one has
interrupted their meetings to come over
here so that they can jointly hear this
with us so so what I what I think I
heard you say in
summary is that every kid who's already
coming through the system is it's the
same kid but we're now going to be
taking a look to see if we should be
setting up a particularly specialized
account for them but I'm still not
hearing an estimate of how many of those
kids are going to need one of these
accounts
I think that goes into the point about
the eligibility that this requires an
eligibility for every kid coming in and
we don't do that currently so so we have
a population number that we're going to
be looking at that seems to be the same
number that we're going to be looking at
in the future and then if we could just
apply a reasonable
percentage you like 50% of them are
going to need a special account 20% I
mean then we can start to wrap our head
around the volume of of accounts that
will be established so there there's
approximately 1,500 children coming into
the system every quarter okay but you
have I think what's really important to
recognize is that doesn't mean there's
6,000 new children every year because
some may be that that that figure um may
include duplicates so to speak if you go
from one quarter to the next so I think
1500 is a conservative safe estimate but
it's likely more annually that will get
reviewed but do 100% of them need one of
these accounts established or is it a
subset they and I'm I I'm going to post
postpone the answer to the question I'm
also going to ask the question of is
this going to require any it
implementations or upgrades because it
it seems to me like it's a very specific
very fiduciary intensive accounting
that's going to be done and it's hard to
imagine that we haven't been doing this
yet these systems are already done so
I'm not seeing any it in
here so so I'm GNA I'm going to go ahead
and um put put 1598 at recess uh for 30
minutes wait wait a second do you have
something we're okay can you keep track
of your question all right so um 1598 is
in recess until 2:30
uh with that I'll go ahead and open um
our discussion on uh HB
1573 we have the prime sponsor
representative Pearson here
representative Pearson I assume you you
would like to introduce your bill join
you at the yeah yeah no everyone in
division one uh come on down make
yourself
comfortable
yeah just just give us a second to get
res situated thank
you
all right thank you for your patience um
representative Pearson at at your
pleasure go ahead and begin talking
about your bill HB 1573 and explain to
us if you're going to be talking about
the bill or the amendment or both
yes thank you Mr chairman after last
fall scandal at the bledo Academy of
Gallatin Tennessee where two New
Hampshire children had been placed in
what turned out to be horrifying
conditions the desire emerged to make
some changes in how the placement of
children with behavioral problems would
take
place house bill 1573 in its original
form was quickly and at the deadline
filed as a
placeholder the office of the child
advocate and the children and Behavioral
Health and DCF of the Department of
Health and Human Services groups with
overlapping jurisdictions began the task
of determining what those changes would
be and much to my enjoyment all those
groups came within 95% of each other on
what the changes should
be therefore two separate amendments
were crafted and the children and family
law committee unanimously accepted
0427 because we concluded of the two
amendments it gave better flexibility
and greater speed for the handful of
Youth needing highly Specialized
Care the bill is amended so pause
because I'm I'm a little thick so so
this bill that we have now that's 24
2149 already includes amendment 0427 in
it yes okay okay it replaced the entire
placeholder bill it okay so this is the
bill okay and and so then um all right
and so you're going you haven't yet
mentioned 0980 not yet all right thank
you so the bill is amended pass children
and family law on February 6th with a
vote of 16 to Zer and pass the house on
February 22nd on a Voice vote giving you
the bill you
have I realized there are many
legislators who believe there is a huge
pot of gold kicking
around fewer of us realized that if we
added up what everybody wanted from that
pot of money the expenditures would be
multiple times of the real amount of
money which is just a simple way of
saying that while the chairman knows I'm
the liberal arts guy who pulls people
from their silos to craft great ideas
I'm not a money person I know you are
the financial gurus who know how to make
great ideas play out and we'll look at
this bill with a down the road look at
where we could be when we craft the next
budget but also a right now idea of what
next step or two we can realistically
take with a little bit of money that we
could ask for and I've spoken with
chairman Edwards and chairman Wier to
this
effect the amendment just given to you
0980 H was just finished yesterday with
input from Office of the child advocate
and the Department of Health and Human
Services as to further
refinements Lisa masio from OCA and
Christa Morris from DHHS could expand on
this new amendment I will just say in
closing that the changes enshrined in
this bill
will better help our children in need
and better do the oversight we give them
so problems like what we had with bledo
won't happen
again thank you Mr
chairman so so it sounds to me like what
you're ultimately recommending by
implication is that the finance
committee um adopt this new Amendment uh
09 980 which is a complete replacement
of everything that the house voice voted
I'm not sure it's a complete one a
complete replace all it is tweakings of
sections okay but the ones who actually
crafted this amendment for me would
better speak to that okay so so no one I
haven't uh had the opportunity to read
and think about this new Amendment
neither have I so so I don't know how
good we're going to be at asking
question questions um and we may have to
uh bring you back bring people back on
Monday afternoon after we've had an
opportunity to look at this and digest
it so understood but may I suggest that
the bill is amended prior to getting
this new amendment is the gist of it it
is the the the big idea the what do we
do now to make things better with
98 something
980 being tweakings but yeah I'll take
you point and I'll come back if you need
me to okay and I think I heard you say
that children and family law didn't look
at the money at all that that that
that's been delegated or or passed over
to us to to to to do the complete
financial review well trying to be
flattering the reason is that you guys
are the money people okay no I just I'm
just trying to make sure we understand
we wanted the policy we discussed the
policy we discussed what went wrong what
could go better that's what we really
worked long and hard on okay so from a
policy perspective um it it it it feels
to me like this bill creates u a very u
a much more intensive active uh
inspection intervention where our case
workers maintain their individual
relationship with the patients that are
out out of state and that on a periodic
basis at least once a month I uh go down
and physically check their status uh and
as a result we have a fairly significant
uh requirement in the bill as as as
presented of uh taking a lot of Manpower
and having them travel on the road uh
focused on on an on-site inspection and
a return with all the documentation that
that's kind of the operational burden uh
that's in this bill and that you
imposing a new contractual requirement
in here as well so I assume the
contractual requirement is meant to um
establish specific care standards uh for
uh the contractor yes the only thing I
would add to that is if we deem the
number of visits per year to be X yeah
and we can't get there right now but
maybe in the new budget we can we'll
take half x 2/3 x 1/3x it is the money
that you folks in finance deem you can
provides from what we have now to to do
better what we've been doing so so you'd
be okay if we proposed a half X solution
I'd be thrilled it's better than what we
have all right so so as an alternative a
strategic policy alternative instead of
sort of this intense sending of of
people to on site did you consider um U
at a contractual level obligating a
level of care and then sending somebody
down to audit the contract and
Sample the the delivery of the contract
as a less expensive but possibly as
effective approach to this bill giving
that it is the people behind me who do
this and understand this and given the
fact here we are now and aspirationally
here where we'd like to be we would be
very happy for finance to put a spot on
that
Journey okay it so we'll we do you have
anything are there any questions for
representative uh
Pearson she I'm looking at her or did
you have one representative
walner I guess what I would like to know
maybe this is more for the chair than um
for representative Pearson but I would
like someone to walk through the changes
from the bill that was voted on the
floor to the amendment since Finance is
going to be coming out well probably
maybe uh finance will be coming out with
an amendment that changes policy and I'd
like to know what it is we're changing I
would would be extremely happy to answer
that through the people sitting behind
me that's what I thought you'd
say maybe LBA could make us side by
side I'm sure they would agree does it
need our LBA left so good timing they
represent guire uh so so keep that in
mind until Mr Ripple while you were out
of the room representative McGuire put
some more work on you what what would
you do you want to turn on your mic and
suggestion representative walner wanted
to know the difference between the
proposed amendment and the bill is
passed by the house so I was saying
maybe you could make a side by side to
do that I can do that all right thank
you can you do that by Monday afternoon
Mr Ripple because that's when we're
going to rehear this all right um Mr
chair okay um go ahead keep in mind we
do not even have a fiscal note an
amended fiscal note for what we passed
last week
uh that that's a that's a good new Point
thank you um Mr chairman this becomes a
bit of a chicken and an egg we can't
give a fiscal note if we don't know what
you're willing to agree to maybe you
don't know what you're willing to agree
to until you see a fiscal note all right
I I'm not sure that's I think our
process is more sequential than that but
well that's cuz you're not a liberal
arts guy like I am yeah represent H
thank you than you Mr chair um I assume
some others are going to come speak to
this bill um am I correct in assuming
that there there are more people here
already to come speak okay because I
would like to know how many children are
involved in this that that's a fine
question now for our new division one
guests um the original Bill had expanded
the Manpower in the Judiciary I don't
know if you've noticed that in the um in
the fiscal note that we have in front of
us I don't know if that fiscal note is
still at all relevant but um on the
second to last page at the bottom they
they they think we need to add two
judges and seven people in the clerk's
office and that's why you all were
invited here um and if you have any
questions I want you to know that you're
free to ask them in this session so um
all right representative or
representative Pearson I I think we're
ready to augment you with uh somebody
from the Department thank you all right
thank
you
hi there my name is Christa Morris I am
the director of intergovernmental
Affairs for HHS and with me is Rebecca
good afternoon Rebecca Ross director of
The Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health of
DHHS okay so I I did are you familiar
with the amendment or or not yes I am
okay are you able to uh at least
partially address representative
wahner's question about
what is in the amendment that changes
the bill that was voted on by the house
what the specific changes were sure
there are a few items one includes the
purpose and findings and that was to
include some um language that is more in
line with the federal standards
regarding kin
and
um and treatment and then also we remove
the word qualified because that does not
really mean anything outside of funding
for for uh certain types of facilities
and not all facilities are considered
qualified that is just for foster care
title 4 funding so we removed that to
allow us to have a larger breadth of of
facilities we could send youth to we
also have uh I'm
sorry Mr chair no could you ask if we
could get line references where she's
talking about oh I'm sorry yeah that
that helps us if
yes so the purpose and finding that was
so start with the first point you made
sure yep that was
um this one I might actually phone a
friend and ask the OCA to come
up whatever you needo yeah if they're
here let's do
it and then you could sit at the end of
that table if you want and use that mic
right there just introduce yourself so
that we've got you in the
record sorry I don't mean to be lurking
behind you
guys Lisa masio I'm the attorney at the
office of the child advocate um
technically my title is the associate
child advocate and I'm here on behalf of
the office Kristen and I worked very
closely together drafting these
amendments so first is the purpose and
statement um
that's where I'm I'm meing on you for
that one
over um so the way we drafted it isn't
exactly because it wasn't a replace all
originally but now I see it is a replace
all so the I I need to know one way or
the other the the chairman before you
who introduced it said it is not a
replace all it's he he described it as a
tweak to what the house voted on since
it says replace all I will defer to the
Amendments language replacing all okay
okay very good so it would be starting
at line 16 of your amendment that Roman
4 residential facilities being
appropriate for children who cannot
safely receive clinically appropriate
care so we did tweak some of the
language from the oca's point of view a
lot of the language tweaks are just to
create more trauma informed language and
be more inclusive for the types of um
issues that the kids in care have we
also added in some of the was adding
back in um language that was in a
different amendment that didn't quite
make it through it was just some of it
was really just copy and paste issues so
one of the big things getting added back
in was this line at it will be your line
18 that a shortage or lack of foster
family homes or community- based
resources shall not be an acceptable
reason for placement in a residential
facility that was really the big thing
that got added back in the rest of the
statement and purpose of findings is
identical to amendment 0427 that was
adopted by the house a couple weeks
ago do you want me to keep going okay
sorry um so then the second part of the
amendment is
section two of the bill which starts on
your page two line six you'll notice um
page two lines 12 to 13 there was a
strike out in the bill as a adopted that
oh I'm lying that is still struck out
but the word qualified is stricken at
the beginning of that paragraph So as
Christa mentioned um they went through
and struck
qualified residential placements
um section three of the bill starting on
page two line
18 in um sort of the copying and pasting
amendments in children and family law a
couple of sections were left out of the
amendment um so this adds back
in nope it does not I am kidding sorry
I'm seeing this amendment for the first
time as well uh so oversight cordor plac
so this language just changes a little
bit it's not really a substantive change
on page two
Section 3 Lines 20 to 33 it was really
um just the
wording of that section about this is
what a dcyf or Juvenile Justice um case
worker who currently is already required
to make monthly visits to children on
their case load and I think in Two Bills
ago you heard what those case loads were
those monthly visits are already
required under statute and are already
in fact occurring um this just sort of
of fleshes out the information gathered
during those visits and then adds back
in a lost paragraph paragraph Roman two
of that section which is your lines 34
to 36 that there will be a new form
created um for those visits with the
DHHS in the office of child advocate
working together just to make sure that
visits are happening um
consistently you you you you said that
uh the sections 20 through 33
three we're basically cleaning up some
wording that's already in current
statute as though the obligations under
that section are already in
law or is this is a cleanup or adding
new requirements this amendment is
cleaning up language from the prior
Amendment it is creating a new section
in
169f okay the policy is already in place
this is already happening DCF workers
already visit kids every single month
this is just sort of explaining in
statute versus in policy or
administrative rule what those visits
entail so we worked together to make
sure it was within the purview of what a
social worker could do and make sure
that the language would make sense to be
able to implement with the workers all
right I'll let you continue U I'll ask
you later about if it's already
happening in policy what is the benefit
of having it in law but but we don't
answer that now let's just keep going I
had a whole intro Spiel to start to
start representative hole do you have a
question I do because right now I think
all she's trying to do is introduce the
major
changes so if I'm reading thisly use the
mic if I'm reading this correctly right
on page three section
four I know is now section three and I
don't know what happened to section
three that was why I was also confused
it looks like section three
became underneath that starting at line
37 on page two that was also my
confusion it just got swapped around
somehow okay so it looks like original
section three became well no section
part of section section four is this
original yes so original section four is
now part of section three and original
section three is tacked on at the end of
that new piece correct I think so as a
reasonable conclusion there that we
really ought not to pass this amendment
as is because it needs some cleanup no
it's correct they just I think when OS
took it they just swapped two sections
around everything's in here it just
isn't in the order that we put it in
there is one item okay maybe there's
something it feels like we need a clean
amendment that has all the sequencing
right well we just re so what I had
submitted to uh chairman Pearson was you
know break down change this section
takes change this section what we
received here is a replace all so we
haven't been able to go through to make
sure everything has has been changed and
sometimes OSS likes to do the numbering
their own way instead
of okay so I'll I'll just leave you with
the basic request then since this is so
new this document and it really needs to
be right would you just please make sure
you go through what OSS produced and if
there's any sort of modification to make
sure that the OS version is is precise
and correct see if you can get those
changes done and maybe a new amendment
number issued by Monday afternoon
absolutely thank you we can do that so
uh go ahead represent I would go a step
further and that new amendment number
also have a compare back to the bill as
passed by the house the first time
through we can do
that okay so this complicates the task
we just gave Mr Ripple we asked him to
do a side by side of these two
amendments um and now there might be
another just clean up I think we can I
think if we're going to consider a new
amendment that is cleaned up that's the
one we need the side by side we don't
need it through all the iterations along
the way we just need the bill as passed
by the house and this new amendment that
we're going to see on Monday okay that
makes sense to me so don't jump on this
immediately until we get the Department
to say that they think the OS version is
correct okay and and if it helps the
version we worked on drafting that has
sort of the just this is what's
changing might be
helpful to to Mr Ripple it will be but
to the legislator you can't help us we
just what we need is we need a clean
bill to vote
on so representative wer do you have a
wer and then representative
f i I have an observation here as I'm
looking through it I I remember on the
first page we talked about taking out
the word quality
qualified and then I go to on the latest
version I have 0427 H down on line
26 169 F6 I see again prior to placing a
child in qualified Residential Treatment
should that word be in there or should
that again be removed so 0427 H is what
was passed by the house on the floor the
new Amendment will strike qualified from
that Amendment thank
you
this is a question from Mr
Ripple so is there any progress yet
towards the fiscal note for the bill as
amended in the house I believe the
Department's been working on that um I
expect something within the next few
days so we will have that available I
anticipate by Monday and are they then
going to try to tie that in with this or
is this not expected to make
any I'm not sure about that
I I think the fiscal know is pretty
critical to the decision
making so what I'd like to be able to do
is get back to the crosswalk of of of
the bill because we stopped you halfway
through but representative McGuire do do
you have a question you want to ask here
well sort of because we have to we have
our own stuff that we have to get back
to um I'd like to jump ahead if possible
to the section that concerns division
one the Judiciary costs which is on the
amendment page five line 10 I
believe right section
three uh Roman
3 so in this section it says that the
judge will review the pl this is line 17
judge will can review the placement
every 30 days I I'm I'm not tracking
with you could you I'm on the amendment
the amend page five page
five um sections three Roman three
starts on line 10 ends on line 17 okay
okay and on line 17 there's the number
30 days and when I read the fiscal note
it said that currently they the judge
reviews this every 90 days and we
effectively have one judge one full-time
judge equivalent does this process so
therefore if you're going to make 90
days into 30 days you need three judges
right and so three a judge is a million
doll plus thing because each one comes
with several Clerks etc etc so my
question
is um is it really NE if the social
worker is visiting the child once a
month why does the judge have to be
involved so often right I mean couldn't
if the the how does the judge know more
somehow than the social worker couldn't
the if if the HHS social worker
discovers a problem they tell the judge
the judge gets involved right but but
isn't 90 days
enough as
yeah so we would say
no um I didn't get to do my Preamble
here so the bledo uh report which we
have copies of here although only for
one Division I didn't realize we were
having joint division um the the issues
that representative Pearson alluded to
at the beginning of his testimony the
offic of child advocate is tasked with
oversight of um State Child serving
agencies including dcyf Juvenile Justice
and their contracted providers including
residential placements one of um an
important part of our job is visiting
children in residential placements both
here in New Hampshire as well as um out
of state we visited uh two children that
were placed in Tennessee which was
um certified by the state of New
Hampshire and being paid as a level
three therapeutic treatment facility
when the child advocate and one of our
assistant child Advocates arrived they
found what looked like a Detention
Center children in prison style
jumpsuits barbed wire cameras children
sleeping on the floor eating on the
floor we immediately called uh dcyf to
bring this to their attention that the
state of New Hampshire was placing
children and paying for children to be
receiving a level of care when in fact
they were essentially being incarcerated
down there those children were returned
within a couple of months um and these
conversations started so that's really
the the beginning of this bill and the
work that we've been doing with DHHS as
well as some of the providers since that
time there's many pieces to that
oversight in this bill one piece is the
oversight by the actual case workers
which was the piece we were just
discussing a moment ago they already do
monthly visits the concern is seven
different workers saw these children
seven months in a row nobody raised a
red flag about barbed wire and prison
and jumpsuits concerning which is why we
felt it needed to then be in statute if
the current certification rules if the
current process if the current visits
weren't working which we would consider
that to be a not working it needed to be
in statute so that was that that 169 F
piece we just spoke about another large
piece though that we heard from the
Judiciary because part of our oversight
is we have contact with the division
with attorneys with the courts the court
reflected to our office that they
weren't getting enough information they
make the order placing the child based
on the worker's recommendations
typically based on what's available and
the level of need which is based on a a
cat assessment level three level four
level five so the courts were telling us
we are proceeding with just what they
give us that you know this kid needs to
be in a level three the bed we found is
down in Tennessee it's a certified
facility go so this judicial oversight
piece is an important part of the puzzle
because again we have different branches
doing different things so this really
builds out that oversight right now it
is every 90 days for children in CP care
this section if you look above though at
at lines
um 13 to 14 it would be every 60 days
the 30 days only comes into play If the
child or a representative of the child
disagrees with that placement but
children should only be in residential
treatment facilities for limited periods
of time for only specific treatment
reasons unfortunately children languish
in residential care when they should be
being brought back to their communities
so that Court oversight piece was a very
important part to increase the level of
Touches at the court system who felt
like they weren't sort of having enough
information to review more frequently so
we don't believe 90 days is sufficient
particularly for these children in
residential care um I can tell you as of
the end of January um the data that the
OCA has which doesn't include a handful
of bcbh kids there's
122 Child Protection placements so
that's through dcyf Child Protection in
group homes or residential care at this
juncture um or at that juncture so a
little over a month ago 241 of those
kids are right in New Hampshire 54 were
in New England not New Hampshire only
two were outside of New England so are
are you still answering the question
posed by representative McGuire of why
30 days make sense in instead of a
longer period of time for judicial
review it's a very limited number of
children that may require 30 days and
really 60 days would be the standard
there it'd be even rarer for it to be 30
days follow up so you're basically
saying the judiciar fiscal note is not
correct I guess yeah I have not seen the
judiciary's FIS schal note I have not
really had an opportunity to talk to
them this would increase um this would
increase judicial oversight you it would
have more hearo so this this is a good
segue uh the chairman of division one
whispered in my ear that he doesn't
think you all can really engage us until
the the correct fiscal note comes out
and it's not out now uh so he he rep
representative hold before do you is
your question relevant to division one
it is
so it's a question of process
right if the office of the child
advocate notes an issue or the parents
note an issue would not a better
response be that the judicial branch has
to respond within a certain period of
time as opposed to a periodic reporting
for all cases so if if there's an issue
that's flagged either by the parents or
whatever the guardians or flagged by the
OCA that then triggers the Jud IAL
Branch to do something within a 30 or
60-day window as opposed to every case
going through the 30 or 60 day window
there's a huge difference in workload
between those two I appreciate your
question because that is an important
clarification so first of all the OCA is
not a party to these cases so they we
would not be an office that would bring
it up it absolutely could be the child's
parent Guardian Casa attorney in cases
this particular section only applies to
children in residential treatment
facilities not kids in fost care not
kids in relative or kinship placements
which is why I brought up that 122
children so out of the almost 1,200 kids
in care only 122 of them could this
possibly apply to do you have a followup
I do I guess the this question still
holds which is a if there is an issue
brought up by whoever is visiting the
treatment facility or the respective
Guardians and parents of the child
either one of those could trigger an
event to go back through the cour court
for additional changes to the court
orders but having something that is a
periodic review for every child of that
1202 adds additional costs where there
it may not be necessary it assumes the
the process is broken for all 122 if you
force the judicial branch to review it
every two months if you set it up as a
triggering mechanism that the court gets
involved at the request that might
further reduce the workload and the
costs should
so not that we're done but division one
needs to go do division one work um we
we'll we'll invi invite you all back uh
on Monday because I don't think we're
going to be at all done today we're
still just sort of exploring this but
but just to tell you my reaction so far
is is that the people who really care
and have been doing this have built a
methodology that assumes um 100%
inspection for all kids frequently and
and that a lot of money goes into that
and that the judicial system is likewise
obligated to have the operational
capacity to do this on a on an on an on
an ongoing basis and I'm wondering if
maybe it's a first step since as I
understand it blood so was a really bad
example of something that happened once
that that I'm concerned that we may be
uh doing a little bit of Overkill that
that that the method that we should be
looking at is uh do a good contract
because we're not doing contracts now
that obligates the recipient to to do
the right thing uh send somebody down
periodically to go audit the contract
and the execution of the contract uh
whenever there's a problem have an
escalation mechanism so so that uh we
can react relatively quickly I it just
feels to me that an audit and escalation
methodology would would be nearly as
effective if not equally effective and
would cost a
tremendously less amount of money with
less commitment to ongoing Manpower
that's that's sort of my theory do do
you have a just a quick response if you
guys considered an audit and escalate
methodology and rejected it for some
reason well we at the department
actually specifically ask that we not
have Contracting involved because of the
lengthy Contracting process and also it
doesn't provide any additional teeth
that a our certification process already
contains so on a good day a contract
sole source push through takes over 120
days while these children are
languishing trying to get into treatment
facilities so we want to get them in
there as fast as possible certification
allows for that flexibility
so does the certification provide enough
detail around the obligations of the
receiving
institution that they will take good
care of our kids and is it auditable is
the certification auditable so so we may
not even need a new contract requirement
if we're doing this an effective
certification as long as something can
be audited and spot inspected correct
our staff has the ability to go out in
in
reinvestigate I guess or recertify um if
they see a see an issue I refer I defer
off to Rebecca because she's her team is
the one that does the certification
process okay so I'm going to listen to
you but I I my main question here is was
this alternative methodology of audit
and spot check and escalate uh
considered relative to
operationalizing the ongoing uh
proactive um inspections I believe that
the bulk of this bill sir is exactly
what you're describing other than the
fact that Contracting did get
removed I we jumped right to the court
oversight piece but frankly all of the
the other pieces really are a sort of
intensified audit system just as you
described initially with touch points
for enforceability that don't currently
exist or are not currently being
utilized under the administrative rules
so so we can talk more about this after
this hearing and and and on Monday but
the the distinction to me between an
audit and what I'm understanding from
this is an audit is relied relies
heavily on
sampling and and this doesn't feel like
it's sampling this feels like it's a
all-in approach and I I think I that's
the distinction I'm making when I use
the word auditing so um did you did you
want to make us smarter go ahead yes I
think I can help clarify that the bill
includes two components one is the child
specific visits that each individual
case worker is seeing their own youth to
build that connection and support that
youth in care every single month that is
one part of the visits the other are the
certification team visits every other
year we certify these providers for
payment based on their quality standards
that includes a sampling of Records
interviews of Staff in that audit
procedure every other year this not a
certification year we do technical
assistance we go onsite we do a similar
procedure but not for issuing the the
certification but providing technical
assistance and ensuring they're meeting
our standards and requirements those
administrative rules are due for update
and we certainly intend to make them
more robust and consistent with the
statutory changes that have occurred
over time but it really truly is an
audit and quality assurance process when
our team goes out for example we have
two staff down in Connecticut today at a
facility that serving seven New
Hampshire youth some voluntary and some
through court ordered placements and
they're meeting with kids they're
meeting with staff and going through
records and doing that audit
process if if does the committee have
any other questions does the department
have anything else to say before I close
this out and say I'm looking forward to
seeing more detail on Monday
representative Earth yes I have a quick
question uh and proba they may not be
quick but I have a question um so sounds
that this whole thing is driven
by somehow we put a couple one or more
children into a prison and this seems
like gross Overkill to determine that
fact how did that happen in the first
place so if I could add to that
it did the blood Soo incident happened
because we did not provide profic
adequate um guidance
or or just did they blow it did they
they just fail to deliver what they said
they would do wa who who what broke here
them or
us that was before my time I really
don't have an answer for you um but I
can find out more information as to
where that that happened in the
chain that' be very useful information
don't you given that we're basically
putting in place this huge process of
following every child every couple of
months for something that sounds like
was a disastrous
mistake we have a report to answer your
question representative
F just a couple of sentences would be
helpful how do we want how do they want
up been
prison so the office of child advocate
um in part of our oversight does these
visits I would say well this was one
incident that we caught in the
conversations that occurred
afterwards there were larger concerns
that this might not be isolated because
the way the system was set up the visits
that attorney Ross was talking about we
found out never happened at bledo they
certified bledo when a full year and
recertified bled Soo without ever
in-person visiting that facility to
conduct the
required certification under the
administrative rules we found out during
those convers ations that a lot of
facilities had not had the required
number or depth of in-person visit that
before placing children there so that's
one
issue fair enough so this sounds a very
simple
solution before you place somebody in a
facility you go and visit it and you
determine it's a prison or not or it's
even better than that I mean this
doesn't sound like you need to do
follow-ups on an ongoing basis when
you're saying if I heard you correctly
nobody went down to this facility to see
hey this is a prison I mean I think I
could detect a prison and it sounds like
you made it pretty easy to
detect and unfortunately seven different
case workers from DCF visited that
facility in the seven months preceding
oca's visit and not a single red flag
was rais and I I not sure that there was
a drastic change in the month prior but
this is this is feeling like we need to
shut this down for today not that we're
done but that I'm just wondering if um
we should do what's your experience with
doing subcommittees on something like
this I I yeah
um o o okay so um so so let's let's go
ahead and and and go ahead and keep the
Monday after afternoon date um but um
let's talk about a subcommittee because
it just feels to me like there's just so
much going on here and so many questions
to ask that will significantly
significantly alter the financial impact
of this bill um that we should we should
really get somebody to from our
committee to bury burrow into it okay so
so who in division three representative
Murray I know you're a guest um um but
who on division 3 would like to dig into
this deeper and be on a subcommittee I I
think I would like to be just just
because I think there's a a systems
thing here and I I have a systems
background so well I might like to be
unfortunately I'm going to be gone from
Friday until next Wednesday yes sir
don't rub it
in representative Stringham and
representative Mooney I don't want to
put everyone on the spot representative
priest do you want to are you ready to
dig into something new Jump in you seem
to have the background where you where
you could help us figure this out I'll
be glad
to so so we have two people on the
subcommittee unless you're you're going
on vacation as well aren't you do are
are you personally interested in
this okay so so the subcommittee will be
me representative walner representative
U priest uh and representative um PRI or
walner would you like to chair the
subcommittee sure all right thank you
okay so so the point of contact is as
you keep going is representative walner
and she'll keep the other two of us
informed I'm personally available for
conversations 24 by7 so just give me a
call if you want to like brainstorm
something something or or like tell me
some dirt that you can't say in public
that would be okay um but uh with that
I'm getting ready to close
um
1573 see you
Monday thank
you I'm I'm uh I'm going to call out a
recess uh 1598 I think we had like three
more minutes of questions and and stuff
to ask about 1598 this is uh relative to
DHHS management of Social Security
payments and veterans
benefits and Miss moris wh while while
you guys are thinking about this think
about whether or not you need any it
changes to manage all the shuffling that
you guys think you
need thank
you who who was up for 1598 when we
recessed okay I hope you remember where
we were at because I do
not U chairman Edwards thank you very
much again for the record uh John
Williams from the Department of Health
Human Services and with me is Attorney
Laura young litigation Council
Department of Health and Human Services
uh Nathan white CFO agj
just did you have a question to start us
off representative walner yes I do and I
I talked with um John and Nathan
actually about this bill so when I
drafted the
bill the real thought behind the bill
was children who come into the system
already being eligible for Social
Security Disability or a death benefit
because of a a parent had
died the intent and that was this is my
fault I'll take the blame for it I
modeled it after Arizona and the intent
was not to go really it was to address
those children who already were eligible
and who came to the system with this
benefit not to go out and try to find
find out if everyone else
was
eligible if we took out that
part where everyone else is eligible one
is this still Le I mean would it be
legal to take it out are we causing
ourselves some sort of legal problem
about that or would that be a way of
looking at reducing a lot of the
cost
so
um I I think that's an excellent
question and I think it would depend
upon what the language change would look
like as far as the impact on the
Staffing need I I would still anticipate
the same sort of general fund impact
loss right um that that would still be
there but I would assume there'd likely
be some impact on the Staffing component
but I think we' we'd probably want to
work on some language and then run it
past the fiscal Specialists and and and
the experts on this to get a better
understanding I don't know if you want
to yes I
think I think that would be that would
lessen because in terms of legal support
you would not have that eligibility
right uh you would have wouldn't have
those hearings those initial hearings
that you have for a possible denial of
benefits for example uh it would still
leave like we talked about we would
still need some legal Staffing to
maintain the fidu AR duty of of the
benefits and
safeguarding yes but a lot of the a lot
of the cost it looked like a lot of the
um cost of additional staff really came
around that eligibility going through
eligibility for every child that came
into the system and I think Nathan said
that it was
like probably isn't 6,000 a year but
it's a pretty pretty large number I've
had a question from the beginning that
I've never really been able to get a
good answer to and I surprised that we
don't just have this on the top of our
heads how many children actually have
come into the system in the last year
let's say take the last year how many
came in who were already eligible and
who we then kept their Social Security
payment so I I think I would I would ask
your meaning of eligible because when I
hear as as someone who's practiced
Social Security I hear eligible anyone
could be eligible until we ask Social
Security uh you know that that so I just
want to make sure I'm understanding
anyone who actually anyone who actually
receives it and gets gets a payment a
regular payment so someone has been who
has been determined already eligible by
Social Security as disabled or as able
to receive payments
okay
we could certainly look into that and
get back to you on that figure we don't
have it on the top of our heads so I
mean because we we're we're withholding
These funds every month from these some
way that money is being transferred from
Social Security to the
department yes so so we we can I mean we
can look at every account for every
child and then those funds are used to
offset the the uh service cost and the
service or treatment cost typically
exceed um the amount that we're getting
there right so there's probably some
reporting mechanism that we could look
at but I think um as far as cap we just
have to pick a point in time because
it's going to move every day but but we
we can go back and get you an estimate
great thank you I think that would be
really helpful so we had some so we knew
what sort of what the scope of it is how
many children at any one time might
actually fall into this category that's
correct and I think also knowing how
many go in and out because I also think
that something unique to this is when
we're talking about creating a trust for
example we could have a kid come in we
create a trust they leave and then we
have a new kid come in just just to
remind the committee it's not going to
be a stagnant number when we say we have
400 kids that doesn't mean we'll well
well okay we'll make 400 trust that
could mean we make 600 trusts just
because we have that in andout
constantly thank
you represent Mooney thank you very much
and thank you for being here I was
introduced recently to these two
beautifully written policies uh at
DHHS and I guess I'm trying to justify
they're so nicely done you've got FSU
managing it you've got a representative
paye you've got these accounts all
listed and everything why something like
this just can't be inserted into that
and uh part of the purview of what's
already going on as opposed to um
massive dollars to manage what seems to
be um not exactly enough money to
justify that could you describe or
explain that um why that just can't be
inserted into what's already in
place uh chairman in response to
represent Mon's question uh the
department does have a policy and I
believe the policy we're referring to is
dated December of
2022 and as part of the policy the
universe that we're talking about and I
think it's very much in line perhaps
with what uh represent walner was
referring to of a smaller scope of
individuals that we' serve we do
currently have the policy as it relates
to children who are either disabled
children whose parents are disabled or
the third Co category is parents who are
deceased and so we we do currently do
that but we still our response to the
fiscal impact is that the bill at least
is currently drafted even with a scaled
down version would require some level of
resources by the department and
certainly we're engaged to working with
you the sponsor and the committee on
that as Mr White had said uh but that's
the the response right now it's a much
smaller Universe of individuals that
we're currently identifying um through
that process and I'll stop and see if
tney young would like to save
me yes I
agree do you have a followup are there
any other questions I got I got two
really quick kind of yes no ones yes no
Mr
Williams and then maybe a third longer
one the first one is I'm not seeing any
it systems in here any money for itss so
um so I'm assuming that with all the
accounts and the need to be able to
provide access to the account to the
individual the individuals um not
dependents the other way around um
sponsors uh Prov monthly statements
provide uh Financial auditing
segregation of Duties all of that stuff
that that that we probably have some
process and it support that needs to be
in a fiscal note am am I
mistaken I know that's correct most
organizational representative payes that
do this type of work especially in our
state do have case management systems
that help that
tracking helping the tracking is is kind
kind of distinct because I'm thinking
like my bank account I I have a bank
account and and and this feels like it's
creating the equivalent of a bank
account for a kid so that when they are
out of the system they get whatever the
that balance is so it's it's really got
to be audible it's got to make sure that
we got fraud protection we gota you know
all that stuff do we need additional
processes additional it no no no the the
the systems are sufficient today to to
handle this but it's the legal
complexities in the additional workload
that are the
issue okay and then the second question
is I I see on the last page there's um a
comment about increase general fund
expenditure of approximately 2.1 million
a year and I'm looking at the table and
I should I should I be seeing that 2.1
million a year in this table or is it in
there and I'm I'm just missing it yeah
so um in in the in the fiscal note that
that you're looking at as introduced um
I I think maybe State fiscal year 26 is
a good year to start with so that
includes the $2.1 million Revenue offset
as well as the position expenses so
that's why we're coming up with the the
2.87 there because the 766 th000 or so
represent position Cost Plus the $2.1
million in Revenue
offset okay so that that's basically the
2.1 million plus the 770,000 or so plus
positions okay precisely got it
um and then the other thing I I talked
if Miss rosenberg's here she may have
thought about the answer to this but you
all are are free to answer this um what
I'm concerned about are we creating a
new entitlement are we setting a
precedent here that we need to worry
about um uh being applied to other
programs uh is this is this going to be
a a something unique or is this
something that is consistent with the
way things are are being
done across the
board are you talking about within our
state or are you talking about across
the board yes within the state uh you
know are do we do we set up a accounts
to take Federal monies we receive to
assign it to an individual for their
future personal use is is this a a new
entitlement or is this something um that
is consistent with other practices
within the state that you know
of I believe this would be new in terms
of having uh being a
fiduciary as the state as a DHHS being a
fiduciary on half of children this would
be new okay so we're talking about a new
president um M Miss Rosenberg does that
cause you to want to say something it
does you want go ahead and use that mic
there at the
end I have no idea why you thought I'd
want to say something um I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center and no I mean
the social the federal government has
determined some time ago that funds that
are so federal funds like Social
Security disability benefits for
children who are disabled and SSI
benefits are supposed to be conserved
and used for children and they've
established stable accounts as a me as a
legal method to maintain These funds and
when the state is in legal custody of a
child they have all the same obligations
to act in the best interest of the child
and to follow the policies and laws of
the federal government which would
include conserving funds for children
with disabilities um and the federal
funds that they receive and that
includes using those funds for their
additional needs that they might have
during the time that they're in state
custody as well as conserving those
funds if that to the extent that there
are any funds left to conserve so that
they are available to children with
disabilities remember these kids have
really extraordinary needs so it's not
really it's a federal obligation so so
so two kind of quick ones one is it is
it your position that you think we may
be out of compliance with fed federal
law I think that federal law says that
we have this obligation to conserve
those funds and the Social Security
Administration and US DHHS have been
encouraging states to examine these
policies and States across the country
now are starting to change these
policies and are not continuing to take
the funds so New Mexico because because
that changes the whole conversation if
we think we have a compliance with
federal law issue I think that the
federal government I I I don't know that
I see Mr Williams shaking his head I
can't tell if it's a yes or no or oh God
I don't want to
talk so this is this first occasion that
I've heard this issue being raised um to
our knowledge and I'm going to um have
attorney young respond to it I'm not
certain that we have a federal
obligation the fact that there are
states that don't do this and there are
states that do this particular function
uh I would we'd have to have a further
conversation with um with um attorney
Rosenberg but I this is the first that
in our conversation up to all the policy
hearings and up to this point that I've
heard anybody raise that there's like a
federal compliance issue not not to my
knowledge ask U Miss Young if she can
confirm we don't want to debate it here
no but I mean I don't think we're going
I don't think we're getting audit let's
see if we can pin it down if we have an
out of a compliance issue that that's
all kind of a yes no legal opinion from
the Department um because I'd like to
know if we have an I'm hearing the word
obligation I hear legal obligation I
think it's an obl I think that there
there are a couple things going on there
is an old there is an old US Supreme
Court case before the institution of
able and the stable act under which the
US Supreme Court did say that states
could pocket this money since that time
the Social Security Administration has
issued further guidance basically
stating now we have these methods of
conserving student kids accounts and
that they ought to be utilized so
technically I don't think that the state
is violating federal law but I think
that there is clear Federal guidance
that this is an appropriate use of the
federal benefits that children receive I
I don't diminish uh moral obligations or
social obligations I just distinguish
them from legal obligations is the point
there um and then um oh my God what was
the second thing I it's just right on
the tip of my
tongue oh oh okay so since this money is
supposed to be going to help um with the
the care of children and we're putting
the money in that's Surplus each month
what happens in year two of this account
if the kid has an exceptional need does
the state have an an ability to access
that account for State expenses is or is
this just once it's in there it's always
in there and it belongs to the kid at
when they they're out of the pro
no the idea is that the funds would be
utilized for the child's extort needs as
they arise while they're in care as well
as um being a vehicle for them to be
conserved for later so they can use for
both purposes okay thank you go ahead it
would be just like any trustee uh that's
what we're talking about and she's
talking about able and stable accounts
but that's modeled out of it's you know
a trust that has someone monitoring it
that has a fiduciary obligation to act
the best interest for a need I think the
best example is my favorite which is a
Mercedes we might have a kid who they
believe their best interest is they
would like that Mercedes they have
enough money for it their account that
doesn't mean that the fiduciary that is
monitoring that account is going to get
them a Mercedes maybe we get them an
Ultima instead because they need to go
to work but we're not going to get to
the Mercedes that gives a third party
someone that determines that the
beneficiary's best interest would be to
use those funds so if there was an
extraordinary need and the fiduciary
assigned agreed that it was a need that
was appropriate and also afforded the
best possibility under the funds meaning
if there's if there's a need that
extinguish the entire account that would
be an extraordinary decision by the
trustee to use all of that versus
conserving it for future needs so that
goes into fiduciary obligations which
also goes into why this is complex in
terms of safeguarding because you get
those questions daily this kid wants XYZ
they need this they need to go to this
um summer camp well we have to to look
at that how much money is expected to
come in next year how much money is in
that account is this in the best
interest from a fiduciary money
standpoint and also for that kid and
that's what gets complicated about
making those decisions with the state
and safeguarding with those individual
accounts okay uh thank you I I I think
we've gotten as far as we need to get
today and we'll we'll bring come back on
Monday I I I don't know what you all on
the committee think um
maybe we could figure out what we want
to do with this on
Monday uh with that um I'm going to
close
1598 and uh I'm going to
open uh
1593 is this you representative
Stringham okay you you can introduce it
from stay from here this works yeah that
works okay great uh thank you um the
background purpose of this bill um I
think think to go through this I'm going
to hand out a u
memorandum uh that was
uh uh distributed basically after we
finished the budget last year
pass so this this involves the
disability waiver
program and in July of this year of 2023
uh an element that was included as part
of the budget uh was uh sarily removed
as no longer being uh an appropriate
service to be included under the waiver
program and this was in um this was done
in response uh to a f federal government
uh statement that said uh
recreational activities uh should not be
included uh in the um
uh in the in the in the budgets so
um uh so this this bill uh uh was
introduced in Health and Human
Services uh and uh W with the idea of at
least on a temporary basis allowing
these services that were felt to be
essential as part of the overall goal of
the disability
program uh could continue until uh you
know rather than having them
uh sarily uh uh ripped away basically
without notice as people's disability uh
waiver um budget uh was being reviewed
annually so um uh the bill passed in the
in the health and human services with a
vote of 17 to3 and on a Voice vote on
the floor and now comes to us with a uh
to to discuss uh how much this is going
to cost and and
um uh and where that should come
from um so as I said our banum budget
was built upon the developmental
disability waiver patients receiving the
same level of services they did the
previous bium and then inflating it for
uh you know for the amount of rate
increases that we put in that's how
that's done so what's happened is that
those budgets now have come through
they've been reviewed and element has
been taken out of it uh it's a
comparatively small percentage we don't
know exactly what percent it's probably
far less than 1% of the budgets have
been removed uh but these were monies
that uh under the waiver program we were
planning on spending uh that now is not
uh no longer viewed as appropriate for
us to spend uh and um you know related
to that the federal government would
have paid 50% of that amount so uh you
know Bas basically there's some savings
inside the disability waiver program
it's not large enough that uh we get
we're going to say hey this is found
money let's put it somewhere else or
anything like that it's just going to
kind of roll through and that's what it
is um
so uh if if um you know as uh HHS said
you know this is not a way to kind of
rip out these necessary services but
let's see if we can transition to
something the idea is to create a
special fund outside of the waiver
program that would pay for these uh
already you know regardless of of uh how
quickly we implement this or or pass it
um we're only we're only talking about
one year of eligibility for these
services so if you think about it that
way uh rather than paying 50% of these
services for two years we're talking
about about paying 100% of it for one
year so whatever that number is it kind
of is fitting into the overall spend uh
for the State of New Hampshire that we
were
expecting um logistically it's going to
be it would be a little bit different um
Health and Human Services changed the
original bill that we put in to
prioritize uh you know assuming that
they you know they run out of money in
are appropriation and enough they
prioritize existing developmental
disability budgets they put in the
limiting to one year let's come up with
with something else for the program
itself so uh the the fiscal notes uh
that was distributed today will show
show uh just an appropriation in this um
this bium budget so the amount in there
that uh is suggested now um you know no
recipient would be eligible for more
than $600 of these types of services and
the note I handed around um you know
what what that shows is uh kind of what
we had to kind of services that were in
there that had to be um removed things
like dance lessons horseback riding
lessons uh things I could see you know
some people may feel like that are not
in the program they couldn't afford
themselves that's probably why these
types of
recreational uh activities uh which um
really allow for these recipients uh to
more fully uh integrate and um be part
of the social fabric of New Hampshire is
probably part of the reason why that's
in but I'm sure for each budget uh it's
um paired with meaning each individual
is part of the program uh that one
element is is an important part of the
overall picture so and what services are
available whether it's house cleaning or
or rides to work and so on so um um you
know the goal then if is to be able to
keep those in and allow uh the state of
New Hampshire and the area agencies um
to um transition to something else uh or
if if the can't in these services are
still done figure out some way to pay
for this if the federal government is
not going to under the developmental
disability waiver program
anymore uh there's an uh note of 500,000
we've certainly been trying to um uh
kind of understand exactly how many how
many uh of these budgets are being
impacted um the the first the first
figure kind of came out says how you
know um uh how much did each area agent
each uh does an IND individual Area
Agency uh think they're they're talking
about Services being discontinued three
out of 10 came back and said you know an
average of 50,000 so that's 500,000 a
year or and um so that's 50,000 50,000
per area agency and there are 10 area
agencies so that's a half a million and
I imagine you know Alex can talk about
that a little bit more okay we'll bring
them up but okay and um so they gave us
a dollar amount they didn't give us a
number of of individuals that's correct
okay so and uh that that's not in um not
information you know it's also gone to
uh OS and that's not information that
our current systems that we have can can
kind of easily go out basically you
probably have to audit a series of
individual budgets see how many of them
more impacted and um you know
extrapolate from there which is what I
continue to ask uh anybody who's
involved in these Services if if they
can get some uh more more intelligent
guess work so we know how much money to
ask for I do feel comfortable that
500,000 would be adequate anything
that's not spent obviously is returned
back to the state budget um so but we
don't want to ask for more than than we
need if we don't have to as I said
whatever the number is um there is an
offsetting savings that have gone under
the disability waiver program that
happens with no
uh uh no effort on our part and the same
thing happens
there any are you done yep do any
committee members have a question for
the
sponsor
yes just to
clarify when you said we'd be spending
These funds
otherwise you meant we'd be spending
federal funds otherwise correct and
we're supplanting those with General
funds well if if this change hadn't
occurred we would have spent twice as
much money because we would had two
years and 50% of it would have been paid
by the federal government 50% by the
state government so
therefore um paying % in one year is
equivalent to 50% of those services and
um um so that's that's why I get the net
out effect okay but this also probably
creates an ongoing obligation doesn't it
uh no the the bill um it's it's just
through the end of the
bium so this is a little weird because
I'm a co-sponsor on this bill so so I
have some background to sort of
summarize what I think about this bill
what what what what had been happening
for years is that um we had some
individuals in some area agencies who
had been getting U some portion of their
recreational Services uh
covered um and as new management came
into the department and they took a look
at this component they they you're
shaking your head am I wrong okay um
they they came to the conclusion that we
were uh maybe out of sync with what the
uh CMS had authorized and and that we
had been we had created a habit in some
cases of paying out wck services that
where we didn't really have direct full
authority to do so and so it's been very
painful to that Community to withdraw
what they had gotten used to and it was
very difficult to get them to understand
that we're we're really just trying to
protect the program by coming into
compliance with the CMS regulations and
as a result they they are no longer able
to get what they had gotten used to and
so I think what this bill is an attempt
to do is to um find a way to allow that
part of the population to continue to
receive support on recreational Services
is is that is that a fair summary since
you're the
sponsor yeah although um you know the
testimony and uh presentations by people
who are seeing their budgets impacted um
they uh you know while it could be
interpreted that these are recreational
Services they thought it was part of the
Mandate of the program to provide
socially inte
but I'm I'm relying on the opinion of
the uh people we hire to execute the
program not the people who are
recipients in the public because
somebody has to interpret and and that's
an employee right yeah I but you know I
I I I I do think there's a difference
the the
um whether a
service you know looking at it from 10
from a th000 feet looks like a
recreational service that says hey how
come you're buying horseback riding
lessons for for somebody I can't afford
horseback writing lessons for my kids
and I'm not in the disability waiver
program so that some of it is is you
know trying to make the program looking
like it purely that it's meeting unusual
and unmet needs of a severely right uh
handicapped group okay so so so now I'm
stepping out of the sponsor role
and I want to ask you some pointed
questions if I may sure okay so um so
horseback riding was covered as long as
it was therapeutic it had a therapeutic
person and the part of this that was
covered was that if the kid needed to go
to a recreation event and they needed
some special skilled individual to
travel with them and provide support
that part was reimbursable what was not
was found to be not reimbursable as I
understood it was the admission fee for
example to uh to an amusement park that
that was not uh able to be reimbursed
anymore that that's what I understood
from what I observed on an area agency
and and talking to um Miss santanella
and um others in the department uh
represent or uh M Miss Tilly are are are
you you able to speak on behalf of of
Miss santanella is she a different
department oh okay I I've I've kind of
cited what I think I heard from her and
I if I'm wrong make sure you correct me
later okay um and so so the the
the oh okay
um so I'm not sure what my question is
to you but I'll let you introduce
yourself and tell us what you think you
heard good afternoon representative
Edwards uh my name is Melissa nth I am
an attorney with the Department of
Health and Human Services uh providing
counsel to the Bureau of Developmental
services so uh to the extent you would
like me to answer any questions um I'm
happy to do that but to answer the the
specific question you just asked
um the the there's a difference between
the therapeutic horseback riding which
would still if those assessed needs are
met would still be covered under the
waiver versus horseback riding for fun
um but you are correct in that in an
instance of something that might be
considered recreational in nature while
the admission might not be covered
because that individual still might need
supports to be able to engage in that
activity those staff supports would
still be reimbursable as uh would
potentially transportation to and from
those
activities okay so I think you just
validated what I said
yes just you know if you disagree with
me just put a you know stick in it but
uh okay so
um so that makes me question the $600
per individual if we're talking about
admissions to the things that are on
page two mman Park trampoline parks
movie theaters that sort of thing uh how
did you come up or how did the um um the
the lobbyist come up with
$600 per person as the right number I
you know I do not know I would leave
that to uh Mr kbis to see how he came up
with that um the department was you know
kind of it's not the department
sponsored bill but the department wants
to you know work with
folks okay so so whatever that number is
if it's $600 or 500 or 750 whatever that
number I I'm curious how we determine
that number and then it's that's got to
be 600 times X we need to know some
number of humans that would um take
advantage of this um I I know it's a
first pro year program we don't have all
the data but it would be nice to have an
approximate
x uh I appreciate the question the
challenge is that many times these
Services were rolled into someone's
overall budget so they weren't a
specific line item in the budget
necessarily saying this is paying for
something that is recreational so the
department actually does not have a read
on that that would need to come from the
area agencies uh doing a deep dive into
the budgets for individuals to see what
had rolled up into the overall request
they had submitted to the
department sure that would be the formal
way to get the most precise number
possible but for to get an approximate I
think there are less than a 100 case
managers and this field in New Hampshire
why not just call 10 of them that are
the Smart Ones and say hey in your
experience what what what what numbers
are we talking about and I I don't know
if they would be able to to give that
number to us either to be quite honest
with you I don't know if there's really
anyone that has even a ballpark
estimation yeah the anxiety around this
issue is so intense I'm sure somebody
has a a gut feeling how many uh Mr K
Special K okay did you you want to grabb
that microphone at the end and just
answer that specific question or say
something thank you Mr chairman Alex
kbis I represent the 10 area agencies I
actually met with them yesterday morning
and I told them about this subcommittee
and I said that that question will
probably come up how many people are we
talking
about I did press them as hard as I
could and I believe a rough estimate is
probably less than 2,000 people don't
quote me on that and I will try to get a
deeper dive but a rough back of the
napkin calculation is probably in the
neighborhood of 1500 to 2,000
individuals let's say 2,000 did you did
you get a sense on whether $600 was a
good
number 600 I don't want to contradict
what Melissa said but I believe the
apartment had proposed a $500 limit and
I had requested that that be increased
to 600 $0000 so somebody do the math is
that
$120,000 it's a mill if if everybody
milon of course that's the maximum per
beneficiary so if all 1500 use the
maximum that's $900,000
okay so or if it's 2,000 it's 1.2
million if they use half of it on
average
then thank you for that I wanted to do a
sanity check on the half a million go go
ahead I I think one really important
point if we're doing back of the
envelope math is you also have to factor
in um right now the way that this is
written is that we would contract this
out and we would expect there to be some
overhead fee um so I think it's really
important just to consider that when
we're when we're
estimating can I respond I I saw today
in the fiscal note that the Department's
saying that it's
12% um I mean to me that should be
negotiated and I I would I would commit
that the air agencies could do it for
less than 12% I don't know where that
number came from but um the intention
here is not to create overhead for the
AA agencies the the intention is to fill
the Gap that that's been created so if
if the committee wants to look at
reducing that 12% estimate in the bill I
would have no problem with with half of
that or maybe even less right all right
just just work on that we'll come back
on Monday and see what your the new
thinking is um and the reason I'm
hitting it so specifically here is
because it took a really long time to
get this fiscal note and so I really
haven't had an opportunity to dig into
it but
um I have a different question it's a
it's a question of fundamental fairness
if if we're going to pay say an
admission fee for a kid on in the DD
program to go to say a water
park what is the fairness issue for a
tax pay paying family that is not a
beneficiary of any government programs
why they need to pay for their kid to go
to the very same amusement park there's
there's a fundamental fairness issue
here does and it's a philosophical one
does anyone want to take a shot at
addressing are we being fair to our
taxpayers families with this
program I'm go ahead well I would say to
that that we're not only talking about
children here but we're talking about
about adults this is not a Children's
Program uh you know think of think of a
person who may be 40 40 years old who
lives in a staffed residence gets Social
Security okay you're too much the
fundamental fairness question what why
is this fair to a taxpayer family that
they don't get this same
opportunity because these are
individuals who through no fault of
their own have limited ability to earn
income and are on programs like Social
Security that most of that funding goes
to their room and board and their
shelter they get to keep $75 a month for
toothpaste and incidentals and they
don't have the ability that others do
again through no fault of their own
because of the condition that they were
born with that if they want to go to
karate twice a
month and their parents have been paying
for them for for years they're adult
is it reasonable for the state to say
look let's let's get them out into the
community a couple of times a month and
and their interest as an instrument or
karate or horses could we have a very
limited benefit for a small number of
needy people who again through no fault
of their own and because of their
disability and their conditions have a
limited ability to earn income to have
recreation in their life so that is the
intention of this is to try to fill that
Gap I I think that's a good answer thank
you representative
wner so Alex
um so many disability people with um
disabilities are very
isolated and a lot of these look like
activities that are
really here to help them socialize and
have some sort of a
normal social experience which they
otherwise might not have and which The
General population does have at their
their their abilities are are able to do
that but these are often I mean just
because you go bowling isn't necessarily
that you're trying to be the greatest
bowler in the world but it might be that
you're meeting up with some people who
you talk to have a you know have a meal
with and have some socialization EXA
exactly are there any other questions Cu
uh or any comments uh because I'm
getting ready to stop this go ahead Mr
White I'd just like to point out a few
technical issues um that the committee
should consider on page one of the bill
uh row 12 um the appropriation is made
for the state fiscal year ending June
30th
2024 um the effective date is upon
passage so if the bill passes after July
we would be into State fiscal year
25 um the second uh consideration as
well is currently line 15 beginning on
line 14 any unexpended fund she laps to
the general fund on July 1
2025 that would mean that the funds
would lapse in the next bium normally
you would see the funds lapse within
this bium so that should be June 30th
2025 if that's the intent otherwise
you'd just be balancing the next budget
with whatever laps came from
here would would it be cleaner if we
just had this program start up at the
with a fresh
budget
that's a question yeah fresh budget
year you don't want to answer that
um I I don't know how I would Define
cleaner could I answer it okay do you
have a question represented stream no I
thought you did all right do you have
any other comments
okay can I answer real real quick the
reason that we didn't wait for the next
banum is because as representative
Stringham said these Services have
already been offline for a year if we
wait till to start it up again in July
of next year you could be another year
out so it would be two years so that's
why we wanted to at least try to get
something temporary in place before the
next panium we thought this was a mod so
represent Stringham told you
that we discussed it okay good all right
um if there are no other questions I'm
going to go ahead and close um
1593 uh and open open uh HB
1669 and I'll note that we're 35 minutes
behind but I think we can um start to
gain some steam here uh who's
introducing
1669 oh I haven't seen you all day
welcome representative
Leon thank you Mr chairman I actually
didn't know that you were meeting on
this until I had a good conversation in
the hall it's been a busy day in Health
and Human Services uh I'm here to
introduce House Bill 1669 I'm the prime
sponsor this is a bill that would ensure
that when the department if if the
department chooses to share the
information in the New Hampshire
immunization information system with any
other parties that before they do so
they would ensure that it's able to
comply with our state laws and our state
privacy protections one of those that's
important is the withdrawal system for
the immunization immunization um for the
IIs because if somebody is withdrawing
and then you're pulling their IIs data
from another state but it hasn't been
withdrawn then because we don't retain
records of that withdrawal because of
privacy reasons then they would be
involuntarily pulled back into the
system um so I know that it's complex
but if we are going to share people's
personal data we need to ensure that we
are going to honor their privacy and
their request for this um one of the
good amendments that came in our
committee was to make sure that we're
also not reaching into an individual
healthc care provider's records because
number one we can't do that because of
HIPPA they need to keep that information
for seven years and number two trying to
reach into to the doctor that you went
to in Florida who then pulled your IIs
uh because they thought that your
tetanus might be in there because you
had stepped on some Coral or maybe in
Hawaii because you had stepped on some
Coral that now you don't need to go
overreach in and not just talk to their
IIs because you share the records but
then also go into that urgent care
doctor and reach into their records
because if we create something that is
just unworkable then it's un
unenforceable and we're wasting
everybody's time so there had been a
very significant fiscal note with what
we had initially introduced and um there
is now a revised fiscal note that pairs
it down um to much much trimmer amount
of money um and quite frankly that money
wouldn't need to be spent until such
time as the department chose to share
the information with any any anybody out
of state um that's not currently
happening um but I know that having a
road workor and a framework for what
would need to go into those rfps and
need to go into those processes is
better to do ahead of time uh because
the last thing we want to do is spring
up and come up with uh some new
conditions at the last minute because
we're trying to work together on this uh
and it's that's why we want to think
ahead I am does the committee have any
questions I I I have a basic question in
privacy it's all about risk mitigation
you take a look at the the threat that
you're facing the the risk associated
with having the Privacy um data exposed
okay the personal data exposed and and
then you mitigate it in a reasonable way
if did did your committee specifically
or have you specifically looked at what
the risk the threat is the the
likelihood of a breach or or the
unintentional release of personal data
relative to the cost because the cost of
this is still one more employee for the
state in a time where Workforce is tight
at 100,000 plus a year so so so what's
your sense of the the the threat that
we're trying to deal with and whether or
not 100,000 is is a is an approp amount
to spend well um thank you I think that
it's both threat and need um what is the
need for us to share this information if
there is a potential of breach or a
potential that somebody's will to remove
themsel from the information IIs is not
honored and upheld because it's not just
about a breach it's also about if
somebody has chosen to remove that
information they have the right under
New Hampshire law to do so this would be
to ensure that if that information is
shared with any other body that then
their information is removed from that
other IIs system now if I was in Hawaii
and I stepped on a coral and they needed
to check if tetanus was within the IIs I
could also tell them my primary care
provider so that they could follow up on
that um and they could and there could
be a specific query to to get to my
primary my primary care they also could
just go ahead and give me tetanus um
with my consent at that point because it
might be necessary so I even question
the need for us to share I our IIs
information with other states but if we
were to do that I think that we need to
make sure that any of those data
sharings would honor New Hampshire
law so so we would be diminishing our
ability to Pro provide good clinical
support to our residents out of when
they're out of state and they need
access to this data if we just simply
said that the data should not be
shared we don't share that data right
now now so if we were to make that
decision to share it in the future we
should follow New Hampshire law when we
are sharing it I know this might feel a
little bit belt in suspenders but the
fact that it would need an employee in
order to share it in a way that would be
compliant with our existing New
Hampshire laws um perhaps this simply
highlights the fact that it is going to
cost us at least an additional
$100,000 should we choose to enter into
any agreements with any outside body to
share our IIs information and perhaps
that would be something where we would
prohibit it without um maybe maybe it
could be something where we prohibit
entering into those contracts unless um
unless we are protecting privacy and
that has the cost of another full-time
employee
represent thank you Mr chairman um in
addition to our statutory constraints
right the overwhelming majority at 81%
if I recall right who adopted Article 2
be right relative to privacy of
information I think that compels us to
make sure that we're not sending this
information to other states in any
form and I think sorry if I can say
further with that um we had the
potential that people's livelihoods
would have been threatened for getting a
vaccine that was not required in New
Hampshire but was required to interact
and even go into McDonald's and other
states and if we were to share that
information um that somebody had tried
to withdraw from the registry and shared
it with with new New York and if there
was some sort of criminal um penalty for
somebody to go in um and say that they
had gotten their Co shop but hadn't and
then somebody gets arrested and charged
I because we don't know what the next
reaction to the next disease is going to
be and while we may have had Shadows of
what could happen we need to recognize
that there may be even stronger
reactions next time my hope would be
that we all realized that um we need to
make sure that cooler heads prevail in
everything that we do and denying
somebody the right to go by a meal
doesn't make sense but we don't know
what people will do in the future if we
did we wouldn't need as many of the laws
as we do um and we need to make sure
that we don't just have the harm of a
data breach but we make sure that we
know whether it's necessary to share
this information and what specific harm
could come from a person having their
information shared thinking that they
had withdrawn it from the registry and
then having it come
back do you have a question walner
so how would the
department
assure that this other entity another
state or another
organization is honoring New Hampshire
law I mean how how will they go about
doing that well um thank you so whenever
they enter into an agreement they need
to enter into an agreement around how
information is shared so if we don't
specify this in our statutes they may
not include that in any contract or any
RFP or any other agreement that they
have um I forget all of the terms but
basically it's basically it's mutual
agreements that they have with with
other other entities so if we don't set
that out as a condition for entering
into an agreement with any other body
then it may not may not happen in the
future and I know that they have a lot
to do I know we haven't staffed all we
haven't been able to staff all of the
jobs they have so the more that we can
lay out and make clear as important
because as representative H said 81% of
people said that our personal privacy
and personal information needs to be
protected it would make sense to have it
in statute so that they know that needs
to go into their contracts before the
information is
shared and I I used to be paid well to
be paranoid but not overly paranoid so
sorry if I come to you with some edge
cases but they like that on Wall Street
thank
you any other
questions do you have anything else to
say is there anyone else here that wants
to testify on this bill anyone in the
audience okay with that uh we'll close
the hearing on U 1669 and just so you
know representative Leon um we're going
to as a committee we're going to be
talking about it Monday afternoon so um
we if somebody asks you a question we're
just trying to find out before Monday
afternoon all right thank you uh HP
669 is uh closed
I'm going to open
um 14 minutes late on hb1
1282 there's three bills here all
dealing with child
support just without if if you're here
to
introduce 1282 stand
up okay very good just wait wait a
second if you're here to introduce
1564 stand
up anyone here to do
1564 okay if you're here to introduce
1595 please stand
up okay so you're doing two of the
three you're doing you're you're doing
1282 and
1595 that's
the
theing
that's the duration for child support
okay and then nobody's here for
1564 all right so why don't you come on
up and we'll have you introduce both
1282 and and then after we talk about it
1595 um Mr Ripple
does
okay thank you uh my name is David
Beckford from new Dar and I'm going to
introduce to you uh HB 1282 relative the
duration of Child Support uh there was
an ERA in
the um former in the present law and so
what we've done here is mashed up what
Social Security does for aging aging out
and I I believe it's all okay our
representative B really carried the ball
on this but I happened to know it was
about uh copying Social Security and and
saying okay at the age of 18 you're done
with child support unless you're in high
school uh until age 19 or if you have um
special needs I think it's stage
20 I can't remember
now oh down down at the
bottom
reaches age
21 and I don't know why there there's a
fiscal note on
it I have no idea why that would cost
any money maybe it's to set the
computers or something up that P I don't
know maybe the child support can answer
that okay are you ready for questions
sure okay so um I'm I'm just concerned
about the
interpretation of of um the Bold section
that's primarily on lines 14 15 and
16 and and so I I don't know if I'm just
reading it wrong or if I'm just being
paranoid but does this mean with this
addition that an individual would stay
on this program in pity if they have a
disability or or is or is this a line
that's meant to say something something
about whichever comes
first I'm I'm not seeing the the the
disclaimer whichever comes first and I
and I'm wondering if it should be in
that sentence
somewhere geez I think it stops at the
21 that was I believe the
intent but
uh um yeah we're supposed to It's
supposed to this is about stomping child
support at a certain
age
okay so do you think I'm
misinterpreting I think so but I think
probably one why don't you ask one of
the attorneys from Child report here got
a couple of them do do you have an
opinion on what I just asked on Mr
Williams or or do you have a different
attorney for that part you got John and
Susan bristen here John Williams yeah we
we're not struggling from a lack of
attorneys today I
think John and I went to law school
together I'm Susan bristen I'm the chief
staff attorney for child
support so so did you hear my question I
can re rephrase it I did
um I think the way to read it is
that there's no child no child support
after 21 for any child and even those
that that no longer qualify as a child
with a
disability um because I know that the
huge emphasis is on the child who then
turns 21 is no longer a child and gets
their own um Social
Security you you're applying the or to
the wrong place I think CH is her
point so so we need we need to amend
this no
it
it no child support order may continue
after 21
or no longer qualifies
right okay so then it would be Overkill
to add whichever comes
first
right that's just the the reading that
you would put on there that there's an
implied whichever comes first with that
or well I think I think the point is is
that so we're talking about children
with disabilities they're getting child
support past the age of
18 and it ends either at 21 or if it's
determined that they no longer have a
disability right so you're talking about
whichever comes first is the
ter it might not be either were I mean
somebody they might stay disabled and
they just age out as opposed to suddenly
they're not disabled anymore okay I
think but I understand for your as well
um all right are there any other
questions about this uh what what do you
think the impact would be if we were to
defer this from 1 January of 25 to one
July of 25 to get it uh in sync with our
budget I I think some people at my
office might
cheer why is that just scheduling of
change es to the to the computer system
which is the main um work that's going
to need to be to be done on this because
of of
it emancipation dates are tracked by the
computer so we'll have to we have to go
in and and change the logic to a great
minds think alike before you got here we
asked Dave weers to to go ahead and
figure out how much time he needs to
implement if we did all of these so so
so good thank you for the V validation
of that I always try to agree with Dave
weers yeah it's smart so are there any
other committee questions on on
1282 I'm not seeing any so we'll close
1282 thank you and then representative
bigford we'll we'll jump to um
1595 yeah I'll be back just can you can
you introduce that one for
us
oh you're the prime sponsor
okay I got a couple of things
to pass
out might help
you
oh thank
thank
you I think we're ready when you are
okay very good all right uh my name
again is David Beckford from new darham
and I also represent the town of
Middleton um and I'm here today to
introduce HB 1595
and that is about um creating a formula
for the child support and the reason
we're here to do that is
because we pay to have these reviews
done this one is the most recent one and
it was a cost of
$116,000 and in it they have
recommendations I just read a few
sentences for you so New Hampshire is
one of nine states that does not provide
a formulaic adjustment for time sharing
in their child support guidelines based
on the findings from the case filed data
almost three4 of divorce and parenting
petitions have a parenting plan that
provides that the child will be in the
physical care of each parent for a
significant share of the child's time
the majority 61% of these cases deviate
from the New Hampshire guidelines now
deviation is one of the reasons the
federal government told us we need to do
these every 4
years so that we can find out if we're
our deviations are growing too much and
if they are we need to adjust the
guidelines make uh so anyway the one we
have uh chosen is something like the one
in Oregon which has a formula that was
developed to address the limitation of
the Cross credit formula it produces
more gradual changes in the order amount
when the child time with the obligor
parent increases Oregon leaders report
that the formula has reduced uh
litigation and uh that's 200 Pages there
and part of that about that this is
another one that came out in 2018 and uh
they sent this addendum to us in
2019 telling us attach you will find a
reissuance of recommendation number
three formula for Shared Parenting with
the on page 59 to 62 with the correct
shared parenting formula for a new
presentation of the
results and uh anyway they gave us all
the same thing we need a formula as they
say not just a calculation but a formula
this is goes back in
2009 we have we recommend the New
Hampshire adopt the Shared Parenting
adjustment currently used in Vermont
this involves multiplying the basic
order by
1.5 to account for the additional fixed
costs associated with raising a child in
two homes and subtracting the amount
directly ly proportional to the
fractional of time the OBO spends with a
child as measured in
overnights this goes back to
2004 and it was I was the vice chair on
that committee and we recommended this
again the same thing on shared parenting
situations this is the family law task
force it was created back in
2004 and it has a recommendation
and it says because of the lack of a
formula or at least a checklist of
factors to be considered
parents have difficulty agreeing on
support in these situations the result
is often a feeling that the other parent
is being
unfair anger about that and then
litigation certainly
litigation
so um that goes uh back to then so and
even goes back to 1995 I have another
one goes all the way that that far back
and yeah I'm almost done with the
problem okay I I had a a goal of closing
by four and we can run over but um we're
it seems to me like you're validating
the the policy part of this and the fact
that you've got good references in the
re in in this bill that the children and
family law has reviewed and so from a
policy perspective it's pretty pretty
solid right sure is and and so that
leaves the fiscal issue which is only
about out spending money on upgrading
the it which is another project that
we've sent Mr weers back on uh so so I
don't know that we have many more
questions for you on this because it's
really about the it money since there's
no money at associated with this policy
right there's th this change in policy
isn't going to add more work or workload
to the department is it I don't think so
okay so let me ask you a different
question and and and you've you've done
a good job in introducing it so have are
you familiar with
hb564 I'm going to ask you a question
that you're toally unprepared for
probably okay so so this bill also goes
into the same it system that needs to be
modified in your bill it goes in for a
different part of the law changing the
poverty level standard and and doing
something about making making a poliy
decision about agreeing with the parents
or ordered by the court is is I'm just
for for you and maybe for the
committee uh do does anyone see any
value in trying to to merge these two
bills with an amendment so that there's
just one change to one It system as
opposed to two bills because uh it I
don't know it just feels like it's too
many bills when one might be able to do
it I can help you with that go ahead I
have uh uh prepared two amendments and
one of them would take away the formula
in 64 which is not really a form it's a
calculation because that only helps
people on the as I pointed out before
you have a single
parent uh in the system and that's where
our formulas are designed for guidelines
then you have shared parenting which
both parents 50/50 so they take care of
that and close to it it looks like about
10%
variation so now you got nothing in
between this bill that I'm presenting to
you which I haven't get to the point
where all this I think it's um 18 states
do this type of formula and uh 41 states
have the uh income shares which we've
adopted um and so we can do everything
comprehensively with this bill except
the support
um SSR self support Reserve it's called
and what they're doing is looking to
bump it up because of the
recommendations uh to 130% of poverty
which it used to be one 100% at one time
then it went to 115 now the
recommendation is to go to 130 you
mentioned two amendments are you
planning to introduce those today so
we're aware of them I was down my phone
so so what if we said we could have you
back Monday but I do yeah Monday what I
do with M oh it's back here I I've got
the Amendments written out I just don't
have them in um OS form yes yeah okay I
I think we just need to wait until OS
has published something um so yeah do
you think that might you might be able
to come back with those on
Monday yes I can okay uh representative
Mooney question thank you Mr chairman uh
friendly suggestion actually division
one was so kind to come in and host a
joint session for House Bill
1573 my thought is because these bills
are related directly to child support
formulas perhaps division one should
weigh in inevitably when child support
formulas are
revised increase in court
filings
occur and so for that reason um my
thought is perhaps division one should
uh be a part of the discussion thank you
may I respond to that yes um I I think I
think that's very uh fairm minded of you
I I I would just say that this is a
slightly different situation in that the
only money either of these bills 95 and
64 plann to spend are in it upgrades and
the IT upgrades are both in the
Department of Health and Human Services
where where Mr weers was here so so
although
you know the policy committee has
resolved the policy the only money being
spent is DHHS money which is division
three so so I don't know that division
one needs to come in on this because
it's an IT spend issue not a funding a
policy you know what I mean do you do
you agree or disagree I to
see I appreciate that I do see mention
of the judicial branch just that it may
increase is an indeterminable amount
clause in the fiscal note uh so just
thought it was worth
mentioning that's a good point I didn't
notice that they did get back to us say
we we don't have we just asked them for
another number through LBA and they said
we don't have anything for you terminal
okay they said they can just do it
through the training all right I um
representative Mooney just uh corrected
me um there is a a a line in the fiscal
node saying this may result in an
indeterminable increase in the judicial
branch Branch expenditure so although
it's not in the not in the table it's
it's left in there as a wedge and we
could maybe just get a division one
person to look at this all right um are
there go ahead I just got are you aware
that um the federal government pays for
two-thirds of the cost no I got it it's
in the yeah okay just make sure and
there's possible possibility might get
some uh specialty money I can't remember
the name of it which pays up to 90% but
you we can't use it now we have to say
after the bill is passed and they want
to go down the child support can then
ask for it from yeah lost I think okay
if you get those amendments uh when you
get them would you just forward them to
me and I'll as early as possible and
we'll try to talk through them on on
Monday afternoon oh okay do you want me
to come in too or you just want the well
if you need to explain the amendment it'
probably be a good
idea and and take a look at 1564 if you
wouldn't mind taking an additional task
and see if if 1564 lives within one of
your
amendments it is it does I see a shaking
head okay I I've got the it's always
good to be a yes I have two the
Amendments now if you want to but
they're not the official no no I don't
want to do explanation of them yeah I I
I I want us to stay on track with the OS
because if because if OS doesn't produce
it or they produce it wrong then we
shouldn't be voting for it anyway so we
have to wait yeah makes sense uh are
there other questions for representative
Bickford um I'm going to um technically
open 15 HP 1564
simultaneously and I think we've
discussed it with
1595 are there any other comments from
the Department on either of these bills
is are there any other questions that
anyone wants to have answered on by
Monday on either of these two
bills yeah
you I want to know representative Murray
what do you want to know yeah okay so
with that I'm going to go ahead and
close simultaneously go ahead they've
got one of them ready by looks okay too
late too late okay too late okay send it
when you can uh so I'm going to close
simultaneously HB 1595 and
1564 um at uh
407 and uh final words for the committee
I we we've got representative walner
there I expect that somebody's going to
contact you about the subcommittee we
formed on the earlier Bill if you'll
just let us know what you know uh and
what you want from US Representative PRI
and myself
um
what else welcome representative priest
I hope I hope the your first day in
division three was was adequate was it
sufficiently enjoyable it was all of the
above and it made my mind spin with all
the needed reading that I need to catch
up with on all these items yeah
representative hle thank you Mr chairman
um I'm not sure um there's looks like a
member a private citizen is interested
in written t testimony here I believe
person here um don't know whether we
want to have them share instead of
forcing them to come back a second
time um before we close I I I haven't
read uh this memo uh I suppose it's kind
of standard in the sense that uh all of
us will read it and interpret it and U
put value on it or not you know
depending on what we think of it so so
do you have a question I think it's
point she's here or he's here whoever it
is is here if you like oh is there is
the right author of this here is uh I
don't to speak as read oh no I'm sorry I
thought you were just submitting this
and I didn't know you were
here do you're you're welcome to speak
to
us if you want to no okay I mean it's
pretty all right but I app it okay thank
you okay uh I'll take a motion to
adjourn if there are no
other okay all right that the only vot
of the day we're
adjourned